there are countless unusual celestial
bodies scattered around the vast
expanses of the universe a combination
of various factors has turned some of
them into mysterious anomalies
exceptional even by space
standards some of these objects are
amazing
exoplanets strikingly similar to Earth
While others have never seen sunlight or
experienced heat there are Worlds dwn by
continuous sandstorm While others are
covered by a vast ocean whose bottom is
made of blocks of glowing
ice at the same time in the depths of
multicolored nebuli there are giant
Stars capable of swallowing whole
planetary systems and millions of light
years away from them jellyfish galaxies
cut through the expanses of space with
their shining Stellar
tentacles and today we invite you to
join us on a fantastic Journey to the
the most incredible
[Music]
ones
Cosmo the first in outer
space before we set out on a space
journey beyond the boundaries of our
system we have to decide on the manner
of selecting a planet that resembles the
Earth most from thousands of candidates
what should be the parameters of this
fascinating world and what should we
take into consideration first it goes
without saying that planets favorable
for the Genesis and sustenance of Life
have always posed considerable interest
to
scientists however it is no easy matter
to single out suitable celestial bodies
among a great number of those discovered
by now to have clear-cut selection
criteria scientists worked out the
so-called Earth similarity index or ESI
for short it is based based on several
principal parameters a planet's radius
density and average surface
temperature this combination makes it
possible to calculate the object's mass
approximately estimate its chemical
composition gravitation level whether or
not there is an atmosphere and if there
is analyze some of its characteristics
it also helps establish if there is
liquid water on the planet's surface and
other information the standard of this
index is the Earth with its parameters
assumed is ideal and its CSI equaling
one based on the earth similarity index
all the objects known to us
conventionally fall into three
categories the first one is objects
whose ESI is under 05 these are for the
most part gas and dice Giants as well as
extremely hot or in the contrary cold
objects this is the category most of the
solar system planets and satellites fall
into it takes just one characteristic to
greatly exceed the maximum permiss ible
values for a celestial object to be
unfavorable for the Genesis and
sustenance of life let's take Venus for
instance the radius and mass of this
Celestial body are very close to those
of the earth however due to its close
proximity to the sun and a dense
atmosphere its surface temperature is
extremely high that is why in spite of a
close similarity to the Earth on the
face of it Venus's ESI is not high at
just
44 of course there being any life on its
surface is totally out of the
question celestial objects whose ESI is
within5 to 7 fall into the second
category these objects resemble our home
planet noticeably more they're mostly
Rocky worlds with relatively moderate
temperatures but it can also be ocean
planets and even some large
satellites incidentally a high Earth
similarity index per se does not warrant
favorable conditions for life for
example quite often low mass planets are
incapable of retaining a dense enough
atmosphere while their magnetic field is
too weak to protect the surface from
lethally dangerous
radiation other celestial bodies yet may
happen to be located too close to their
parent star and so get tidily locked of
course all these factors greatly reduce
the chances of life's Genesis and
sustenance as for the Third category it
contains celestial bodies with a high
ESI that is over 7 all of these planets
are beyond the solar system according to
estimates the size of these worlds and
the conditions on their surfaces are
potentially close to those of the earth
among these planets there is one which
resembles ours most and it lies just 12
and 1 half light years away from the
earth this amazing world orbits Garden
star a small red dwarf discovered in
2003 this star is
1,370 times dimmer than the sun this
means that it cannot be observed with a
naked eye even though it lies quite
close to the Earth the mass of this tiny
star is roughly 9% that of the Sun and
its radius is about 5% bigger than that
of Jupiter gravitational forces are
barely strong enough to maintain the
thermonuclear reaction in the Stars
interior that is why the the surface
temperature is just
2,900 kin or roughly
2,630 de
c as is the case for all red dwarves D
Garden star's habitable zone is
comparatively narrow and located very
close to it back in 2019 two exoplanets
were detected in its system after
continuous observations of the Stars
proper motion interestingly one of them
lies beyond the stars habitable zone and
the other
within the outer planet dubbed T Garden
C follows an almost ideal circular orbit
around the system's center with the
Orbit's radius .045 astronomical units
it is completed every 11 and 1/2 days it
is presumably a rocky Celestial body
with a mass 11% bigger than that of the
earth its radius is estimated to be
approximately 3 and 1/2% bigger than
that of our planet unfortunately
conditions on te Garden se's surface are
far from
hospitable due to the low Luminosity of
its parent star the object enjoys 63%
less energy than what the Earth receives
from the Sun as a result the planet
surface temperature is gauged at 47° C
below zero on average which is too low
for Life sustenance at least in the
forms we know it still the chance of
there being vast oceans of salty water
concealed under a the Clare of ice on T
Garden SE as is the case with Jupiter's
satellites for instance shouldn't be
ruled
out as for the inner planet it is dubbed
D garden B it is actually this planet
that is the most earthlike object of all
those discovered to date its CSI is
95 which is just 05 less than the
standard ideal value of our
Earth this Celestial body lies point 025
astronomical units away from its star
and it takes it roughly 5 days to
complete a full orbit around it by
following a practically circular orbit
the exoplanet is constantly in its Stars
habitable zone and it receives 15% more
radiation from it than the earth from
the sun According to some estimates T
Garden B's mass is just 5% more than
that of our planet as for its radius it
differs from that of the Earth by a
minuscule ratio
which means that the gravitation value
is also quite close to what we're used
to on our home planet this makes it
logical to assume that the inner makeup
of the exoplanet is highly likely to be
similar to that of the earth there is a
massive metallic core coated in a thick
layer of M and silicate mantle reckoned
to be at the center of the planet the
celestial object's outer part is covered
with a relatively thin crust of
solidified
rocks mathematical modeling shows that
the average temperature of T garden B is
28° C which is 14° more than that of the
Earth this means that conditions on its
surface allow the planet to have and
retain a notion of liquid water and the
planet's temperature profile is
potentially favorable for most
microorganisms even though te garden B
is quite massive and is capable of
retaining a comparatively dense
atmosphere the radial velocities method
which is used for exoplanets detection
is quite inadequate for obtaining any
information about the atmosphere's
composition but it should be borne in
mind that a planet's temperature profile
directly depends on its atmosphere's
composition for example a dense
atmosphere with a high percentage of
methane and carbon dioxide will cause a
strong greenhouse effect dense clouds of
water vapor meanwhile will on the
contrary reflect sun rays which reduces
temperatures we should also remember
that no matter how optimistic the
parameters of this fascinating Celestial
body might appear it is not entirely
Flawless being in close proximity to its
parent star it seems that te garden B is
always facing it with one in the same
side which causes sharp temperature
differences between the day side and the
shadow side as I've already mentioned te
Gardens star is a red dwarf and this
class demonstrates a tendency to
suddenly flare up the amplitude of
fluctuations in its Luminosity May reach
30% which greatly affects the planets
located close by still the chances of
Teagarden bees capability of sustaining
life are high biological creatures often
demonstrate incredible viability and
their ability to adapt can't but a maze
for example the ocean could serve as
protection against lethal radiation and
sharp temperature
fluctuations it's up ler is potentially
capable of absorbing Cosmic radiation
while its currents could dissipate
temperature contrasts for all we know as
time goes by primitive organisms might
evolve in the warm depths saturated with
energy and
microelements just a tiny chance is
sometimes enough for life to develop
into something
bigger as a rule it's potentially
habitable planets with favorable
conditions and a moderate climate that
especially catch one's attention among
the great diversity of other worlds out
there or else on the contrary extremely
dangerous objects Stand Out among others
still there is yet a third category it's
anomalous celestial objects manifesting
unusual behavior which is barely
scientifically accountable objects like
that challenge our knowledge and
deserves special attention this is
exactly the kind of world we'll be
looking at
now the year
2009 the environs of the Kepler 413
system an unknown object passes between
our planet and a distant star briefly
reducing its Luminosity astronomers take
the event to be a standard exoplanet
Transit and announced the discovery of a
new Celestial body high Precision
calculations even make it possible to
determine its
parameters the planet turns out to be a
cool giant with a mass of about 25 times
that of the earth and a radius of about
40% that of Jupiter
however 180 days later another expected
Transit never occurred the planet so
clearly visible in the old data seemed
to have vanished without a trace a dark
spot in the Photosphere of the star or a
giant dust cloud moving in its vicinity
would have accounted for the mysterious
phenomenon but these hypotheses were
dispelled when 800 days later the
mysterious object reappeared just as
suddenly as it had vanished the
hypothetical Planet eclipsed the disc of
its parent star five times before
disappearing again
still the key to the riddle had been
found it turned out that Kepler 413b has
a highly unusual orbit the celestial
body is located near a binary star and
is 36 astronomical units from the
system's common Mass center its
trajectory is constantly affected by
gravitational
perturbations and the changing
gravitation of two nearby Stars shifts
the orbital plane considerably causing
in cyclic
oscillations when the deviation reaches
its maximum the object leaves the line
of vision and then returns to it
calculations show that Kepler 413 B's
orbit oscillates with a periodicity of
about 11 years deviating 2.5 de in each
direction from its average value the
planet's own axis of rotation also
changes its position significantly with
a maximum angle of inclination of up to
30°
combined with a notable eccentricity of
the orbit and its periodic shift the
climatic conditions on the surface
change in a bizarre way the region that
receives the most light from the parent
star is constantly shifting from the
equator to the poles and back which
leads to dramatic variations in
temperature it is likely that this
process generates huge planetary scale
hurricanes which can be larger than the
Great Red Spot of Jupiter
air currents can carry ice clouds at
several kilom per second gradually
becoming unstable and
dispersing meanwhile the collision and
deformation of vortices is capable of
causing tremendous atmospheric emissions
that have the power to overcome the
planet's gravity and reach outer
space according to calculations they
will hang a while up there before
gravitational forces pull them back down
all these incredible phenomena make the
planet a rather harsh place however it
may seem like a tranquil Serene Island
in comparison to the following
World 190 light years from Earth the
environs of the HD 10606
system this yellow dwarf surprisingly
similar in parameters to the sun is
orbited by a planet with a highly
variable climate it whizzes towards its
parent Star as rapidly as a giant Comet
burning itself in the hot rays of its
Corona only to retreat to the periphery
of the system the object is a gas giant
with a mass four times out of Jupiter
and a radius slightly different from
that of Jupiter at the furthest point in
its orbit the planet is 88 astronomical
units away from the parent star and
receives about as much heat from it as
the Earth does from the Sun it has been
suggested that this is when clouds
consisting of water vapor droplets ice
crystals or even microparticles of
quartz May condense in its atmosphere
and temperatures on the surface of the
hypothetical satellites of the gas giant
could be comparable to those on Earth
but as the planet gets closer to the
star conditions on it change very
quickly within 55 days the distance
between them shrinks by a factor of near
near 30 and the energy flux from the
Star increases by a factor of 800
observations show that the lowest point
in its orbit the exoplanet's temperature
roughly doubles within a matter of just
6 hours from 500 to 1200°
C such drastic changes result in violent
hurricanes which can reach speeds of up
to 5
km/s by absorbing an incredible amount
of heat the atmosphere of the gas giant
expands so fast that it produces shock
waves capable of sweeping across the
entire planet multiple
times water vapor is broken down into
oxygen and hydrogen by the temperature
and quartz crystals evaporate Without a
Trace only to recondense into gigantic
sand clouds
later in all likelihood HD
80606b is the only planet in its system
the gravity of another near by star has
not only warped its orbit but has also
rre havoc on the protoplanetary dis so
the chances of encountering other large
objects nearby are rather
slim however destabilization of a
planetary system due to the interaction
of celestial bodies is not
uncommon one , 530 light years from
Earth the environs of the Kepler 36
system the central object in this system
is a yellow
subgiant its mass is comparable to that
of the Sun and its radius is 62% larger
than that of our star there are two
planets rapidly orbiting the star a
rocky super Earth and a hot mini Neptune
every 97 days they mutually approach at
a critical distance of only 1.9 million
km about 20 times less than the minimum
distance between the Earth and Venus at
such moments their mutual attraction
causes global cataclysms but after a few
days the celestial bodies diverge again
until the next
[Music]
resonance according to calculations the
gravitational interaction between the
planets at the point of closest approach
is about 13 times higher than that
between the Earth and the Moon in
particular this effect should be seen on
the surface of the rocky planet under
the influence of Titanic forces its
crust May Crack and shift causing
earthquakes of incredible power the
resulting chasms may be hundreds of
kilometers long and cause multiple
eruptions of gigantic
volcanoes it is likely that some regions
of the planet do not cool down in the
short period of relative tranquility
creating Seas of eternally bubbling red
hot magma the reasons for the formation
of such an unusual system are still
debatable we now know that the superar
dubbed Kepler 36B is12 astronomical
units away from its parent star and it
takes 14 days to complete a full orbit
around it the super Earth's mass is 3.8
times that of the earth and its radius
is 1 and 1/2 times that of our planet
the object has been calculated to have a
temperature of 980 K or just over 700° C
and an average density of about 30%
higher than that of the Earth the data
suggests that the celestial body could
be a thian planet the core of a gas
giant that has lost its
atmosphere such objects contain many
heavy metals like iron and Lead as well
as sulfur and silicon compounds it is
likely that the light elements that once
made up the thick dense shell of the
celestial body may have been blown into
space by Stellar Wind nor should we
forget the second planet's gravitational
pool which could potentially have
contributed to this
process the object is called Kepler 36 C
and is likely to fall into the class of
hot
mines the celestial body moves in a
nearly circular orbit with a radius of
.13 astronomical units and completes it
every 16
days its mass is 7 times that of our
planet and its radius is 3.7 times that
of the Earth because of its proximity to
the star the temperature of the object
is also very high
928 kelv or
65° C this Celestial body should be
surrounded by a thick M layered
atmosphere
consisting mainly of nitrogen hydrogen
and helium deeper down the pressure
inside the gas shell increases and it
gradually turns into a notion of
supercritical fluid surrounding the
solid core meanwhile under certain
conditions truly fantastic phenomena are
also possible for example the gravity of
a more massive planet can potentially
capture satellites from its smaller
companion while tidal forces May destroy
them to for form vast asteroid
streams in addition the mutual
gravitational pool of the two planets
distorts their orbits altering
eccentricity and other
parameters because of this the entire
system behaves chaotically and
unpredictably and its Evolution cannot
be predicted over any extended period
modeling shows a 91% probability that
the two planets will collide with each
other over the next 70 million years
producing hundreds of thousands of
pieces of debris which will disperse
throughout the planetary system thereby
creating a still greater chaos within it
such tremendous cataclysms may have
occurred more than once in the following
system
434 light years from
Earth a surprising object inly called
super Saturn is located four
astronomical units away from a Young
sunlike
Star it is a brown dwarf or a large gas
giant 20 times as heavy as Jupiter
observations show it to be a young
Planet about 15 to 16 million years old
which is still
forming most of its atmosphere consists
of hydrogen and helium with a massive
metallic core in its depths this object
is spun by a system of rings like
Saturn's but much larger the transit
method had revealed at least 37 distinct
drains with the largest one's outer
radius measuring about 6 astronomical
units this is comparable to the size of
Venus's orbit and about 640 times the
radius of Saturn's
rings according to calculations the
total mass of the circum planetary dis
is bigger than the mass of the earth and
its Behavior manifests signs of
Randomness mathematical modeling shows
that such structures are not stable and
gradually
disintegrate some of the objects making
them up lose velocity and fall to the
central Planet While others on the
contrary accelerate and leave the disc
forever however this process is greatly
extended in time and may take several
hundred million years also a large
rupture with a radius of about4
astronomical units was detected in the
system of rings which is considered
indirect evidence of the existence of an
EXO satellite in this region about 80%
the mass of the Earth according to
current understanding of the physics of
space objects it is a kind of object
capable of clearing its orbit of small
debris forming a wide rupture in the
ring structure in addition observations
suggest the presence of at least two
more celestial bodies with a mass of
each of about 30% that of the earth and
located at a distance of about .25
astronomical units from the center of
the brown
dwarf just like it is the case with the
large planets known to us it can be
assumed that a total of several hundred
exos satellites including rather massive
ones may be located within the
gravitational influence of the central
object a simulation of such a system
including radiation from a parent star
heat flow from a giant planet and tidal
influences shows that the temperature of
the celestial body is making it up could
approach comfortable
values one can only imagine how
enchanting the night sky would be from
the surface of such an EXO
satellite at this distance the brown
dwarf occupies 70 times as much space in
the sky as the full moon and its soft
glow can dispel the darkness and turn
the night into a misty
Twilight instead of the Star Spangled
canopy the planet's sky is crisscrossed
by vast sway Wes of light from Horizon
to Horizon at the same time the tidal
forces of a nearby massive body could
provoke multiple eruptions on the
satellite surface and its hypothetical
ocean could slam the land with giant
waves the width of a tidal Zone under
such conditions could reach hundreds of
kilometers making it a unique climatic
Zone something like a cross between land
and the ocean
floor still it should be mentioned that
structures tend to be unstable and
change their appearance quite quickly
beyond recognition it is difficult to
say how much longer will be able to
admire the giant rings and what they
will look like in millions of
years assumptions about the existence of
space objects the size of a planet which
are independent from any Star have been
around for a long time such celestial
objects freely drifting around into
Stellar space are referred to as orphan
free floating or rogue
planets astronomical bodies of this kind
emit very little thermal and light
energy into space around them it is
suggested that there are no bodies in
their close proximity they could clearly
interact with or be bound to that is why
it is hardly surprising that these
objects are so difficult to detect
the first potential representatives of
this class of planets were spotted as
recently as in the early 21st century
the warmest rogue planets can be
detected with infrared telescopes and
others thanks to something called the
gravitational microlensing effect as one
would expect this class of celestial
objects is one of the most mysterious
and understudied today only three
astronomical bodies can be classified as
rogue planets with a sufficient degree
of certainty with the overall number of
Rogue Planet candidates over two
dozen incidentally according to the
analysis of data collected in the course
of the ogal project the Milky Way May
supposedly be home to up to a 100
billion objects of this class this may
only mean that right now we're at the
very beginning of an upcoming series of
discoveries in this field our Notions of
what rogue planets are like have long
been based purely on assumptions and
hypotheses
with a technological advancement of
highly sensitive observation equipment
there arose opportunities to put them to
the test in
practice the Rogue Planet lying closest
to the earth among those already
confirmed is known as y 0855 -
0714 7.27 light years away from the Sun
it was detected in 2014 with a wise
orbital infrared telescope
the astronomical body cannot be seen
through optical telescopes as it emits
no visible light to speak of the reason
for this is its extremely low
temperature from 225 to 260 Kelvin or 48
to 13° C below
0 in terms of its parameters it
resembles a cooled off gas giant and its
age cannot be under a billion
years the Rogue planet is mostly made up
of
hydrogen however in 2016 the Gemini
Observatory produced evidence of the
presence of large amounts of water in
its atmosphere it is suggested that
water is condensed into clouds made up
of tiniest particles of
ice today it hasn't been established for
certain how this object came to be there
are currently two versions suggested by
researches according to the first one a
celestial object like that starts its
life cycle in the Pro WR a planetary dis
of a regular planetary system
mathematical modeling of this process
shows that if the original cloud of gas
and dust is heavy enough it is highly
likely that at least one planet will be
ejected beyond the system the celestial
object may also be forced out of its
Stars environs if another massive star
passes it by or else if its planetary
system collides with another system the
chances of events like that are
admittedly comparatively small the other
version has it that the space object was
born just like any other star on
compression of interstellar gas at the
same time the mass of the object proved
to be too small to unleash any
thermonuclear reactions in its interior
it goes without saying that in this
manner it may turn out only as a gas
giant or a brown dwarf but not a rocky
planet similar to the
Earth some researchers don't agree that
these objects should be seen as rogue
planets and classify them as sub Brown
dwarves
instead others suggest using the term
PLO for all Interstellar wanders that
don't show any thermonuclear activity
bearing in mind today's Notions of the
makeup of brown dwarves and gas giants
we may estimate the mass of y's 0855
minus 0714 at anything from 3 to 10
Jupiter masses this rather falls short
of starting a thermonuclear reaction but
quite enough to keep the heat
effectively trapped inside the
planet taking into account our knowledge
about natural laws we can predict what
the conditions on the astronomical
body's surface are like for example
according to research by David John
Stevenson from the University of
California in the US gas giants similar
to Jupiter don't cool off instantly
after receding from their star their
thick hydrogen atmosphere is quite
reliable thermal isolation while the D
and hot nucleus made up of metallic
hydrogen can keep the planet heated for
a considerable time estimates show that
the temperature of the lowest strata of
a hypothetical Celestial object's
atmosphere may be high enough for liquid
water to be around it is likely to be
present in the atmosphere as giant
clouds made up of tiniest
droplets these deductions agree with the
results of mathematical modeling of y's
0855 - 0714 carried out by a team of
scientists from the University of
Edinburgh it showed that the most likely
temperature value of the planet's
surface is 250 K or 23° C below 0 the
celestial body's atmosphere also has a
comparatively warm layer around 100 kilm
thick whose density fluctuates from4 to
1.2 mg per cubic cm it is comparable
with the conditions on the earth and so
it is thought that this environment
should be favorable for potential or
organic
life incidentally a planet doesn't have
to be a massive gas giant to avoid
freezing in the cosmos in 2020 a rogue
Planet candidate was detected using
gravitational microlensing techniques
and here is the long designation it got
it is still awaiting confirmation of the
Rogue Planet status and its parameters
have been defined only generally so far
according to preliminary data however
the object object is comparable to the
Earth in terms of its mass and is
anything from 30 to
180,000 light years away according to
our current scientific Notions an object
with a mass like that is not supposed to
be a gas giant and is more likely to be
a rocky planet this in its turn offers
Good Grounds to believe that the object
formed in the protoplanetary disc of a
planetary system as the latter was
forming it may have been ejected from
the system as a result of a cataclysm in
space or alternatively under the
influence of a larger neighbor after
that it was left to its own devices and
so became a free floating Planet what
will happen to it next is predefined by
a combination of several factors
provided the object's atmosphere is
sufficiently dense it will be reliably
thermally
isolated potentially a layer of ice on
its surface could produce the same
isolating effect in addition with the
object's interior score ing hot and with
radioactive elements undergoing Decay
most of the hypothetical ocean will
remain in a liquid
state if the planet happened to have a
moon it may have retained it on ejection
if this is the case tidal forces are
likely to continue to deform and warm up
the lithosphere theoretically with any
luck primitive anerobic life forms may
have stayed around although of course it
would be next to impossible to discover
their traces now most of the data about
the rogue planets we know today were
arrived at following mathematical
modeling and complex
calculations it was possible to do these
calculations thanks to the tiniest bits
of information gleaned with the help of
orbital and earth-based
telescopes even as I speak a project is
being worked on known as
Cleopatra its main objective will be to
search for free floating planets and
other objects in space with subsequent
definition of their parameters the
project relies on something called
microl lensing it is a phenomenon when a
Celestial body passes between a remote
star and the Observer on the earth and
briefly interferes with the light
emitted by the remote star in the
background when observed from different
angles the moment of transition will be
registered a fraction of a second sooner
in one Observatory than in another
referred to as lensing Parallax this
effect allows scientists to gauge the
distance to a detected object as as well
as its mass and
dimensions an interplanetary spacecraft
is planned to be created within the
project it is supposed to blast off the
surface of the Earth as soon as in 2025
alongside a mission to Mars after which
it will enter its own orbit around the
Sun the project will be aided by a
specialized artificial intelligence
component whose mission will be to
process and analyze collected
information the cartra project will
certainly Delight us with a wealth of
exciting and important information so
there is a lot to look forward
to what is to become of all those Rogue
worlds out there drifting quite by
themselves in the dark depths of the
universe in theory an orphan Planet may
be captured by the gravitational field
of a star and become part of its
planetary system but this chance is by
all accounts
minuscule most objects like that are
destined to wander for billion millions
of years through endless expanses of
space while slowly and inevitably
cooling off eventually there to be
swallowed up by black holes or else
destroyed as a result of a cataclysm in
space never to reveal their secrets to
[Music]
mankind the year
as the Starry Sky was being routinely
observed a small yellow dwarf was
detected in the Phoenix
constellation it was later to be dubbed
wasp
96 the year
2013 the super wasp orbital telescope
detected an extremely rarified gas giant
in the immediate vicinity of the
star a preliminary spectral analysis of
its atmosphere revealed that it was
remarkably transparent and practically
devoid of any water
vapor the year
2022 analysis of the object's atmosphere
was conducted again this time with the
help of the new generation orbital
telescope James web which offered an
unprecedented
accuracy scientists were taken AB if the
new data were to be believed the
exoplanet was supposed to be shrouded in
thick layers of clouds which was the
exact opposite of what the previous
observations had
revealed thus the data from the James
web was in conflict with the earlier
estimates and the degree of our
understanding of the universe was
questioned yet
again so what is this amazing telescope
like and what has it seen in the depths
of space so far let's take a closer look
at
it the first out of
space the history of the largest modern
orbital telescope began back in
1996 its development and modernization
took as long as 25 years after which the
spacecraft left our planet and set out
on its journey through
space it took James Webb a month to
reach its destination Point located 1
and A2 million km from our
planet because the telescope is equipped
with high Precision infrared sensors it
can see the dimmest and most distant
space objects hidden in the depths of
the
universe however this unmatched
sensitivity also has a
downside the intense radiation from the
earth the the moon and the sun
interferes with the faint signals of
distant stars and
exoplanets therefore in order to
counteract this effect the super
sensitive instruments were covered with
a multi-layer heat reflecting screen The
Observatory itself had to be moved away
from large celestial bodies and be
located near the so-called second lrange
point in the shadow of our
planet still the obtained results were
absolutely worth all the effort because
James web helped us make quite a number
of Amazing Discoveries pretty much from
the very first days of its
operation with some of them quite
expected others on the other hand
prompted additional
questions one of the studies with a
paradoxical outcome was the spectral
analysis of wasp 96b a glowing exoplanet
of extremely low
density it is located 045 astronomical
units from its parent star and completes
a full orbit around it in just 3 and 1/2
days according to calculations the mass
of the celestial body is half the mass
of Jupiter and its diameter is 20% more
than that of
Jupiter because of the extreme proximity
to the star the temperature of the
object's outer layers is quite high and
reaches
1,285 K or just over 1,000° c x planets
of this type fall in the category of hot
Jupiters and are distinguished by large
losses of atmosphere due to Stellar Wind
earlier measurements showed very clear
lines of sodium in the atmosphere of
wasp
96b which was interpreted by the
researchers as a sign of an unusually
clean and cloudless atmosphere the fact
is that according to the available
models of the structure of gas giants
this element can exist only in the
planet's
interior as we can see traces of it it
means that the upper regions of the
celestial body's atmosphere practically
do not absorb light it was assumed that
thanks to this the ultra sensitive
Detectors of James web could look into
the deepest layers of the
exoplanet however the information
obtained by the telescope turned out to
be radically different the outer layers
of the gas giant contain great amounts
of water
vapor it condenses in the upper
atmosphere spere and can form a large
Haze or thick clouds reflecting some of
the light shed on it because of this the
temperature of the lower layers of the
object May differ significantly from the
calculated
values perhaps the accuracy of the
earlier study was insufficient or else
some of the data was
misinterpreted it is also possible that
we do not yet know of a certain factor
that would allow us to combine the
results to form a single correct
picture wasp 96b remains a mystery which
means it still needs to be studied in
more
detail of course James web's discoveries
do not end there for example 69 light
years away there is an unusual system
consisting of three Brown dwarves at
once these Cosmic bodies are too big to
be planets and at the same time too
small to launch a stable Thermon nuclear
reaction in their
interior Brown dwarves are usually
difficult to detect as the radiation of
their surface is extremely low but James
web sees the universe primarily in
infrared which makes it easy to
distinguish objects that are virtually
invisible in the optical
range the two largest components of the
system are very similar in their
characteristics and are located quite
close to each other the distance between
them is about two astronomical un units
and their total mass is slightly more
than 100 times that of Jupiter the
temperature of both objects is
relatively High reaching 2,600 Kelvin or
slightly over 2,300 de
C the third component of the system is
at a much greater distance about 100
astronomical units from the center its
mass is between 14 and 23 Jupiter masses
and its radius is 20 % more than that of
Jupiter also this brown dwarf is about
twice as cold as its more massive
companions observations reveal that the
temperature of its outer layers is
1,240 K or slightly below 1,000°
C nevertheless the celestial body is
considerably warmer than the gas giants
in our system especially given the
absence of a star that would give it
heat it was surprising to find mind that
the outer layers of this brown dwarf
contain not only the usual components
such as water methane or carbon dioxide
but also minute particles of various
silicon
compounds the simplest of these is
quartz but more complex substances have
also been
detected these are thought to be
concentrated in the atmosphere of the
celestial body in the form of vast
clouds the existence of such clusters
had previously been predicted from
theoretical considerations because
silicon being a product of Stellar
thermonuclear reactions is quite
widespread in the
universe still until recently
observations have not been able to
confirm this
hypothesis it is thought that about 140
million years ago there was a single gas
dust cloud in the system's place which
later split into three independent
clumps this event may have been caused
by the gravity ational influence of a
massive Celestial body that passed close
to the protostellar
nebula remarkably if the separation had
not occurred the total mass of the
formed object would have been enough to
start a self- sustaining thermonuclear
reaction in this case instead of three
Brown dwarves we might have been
observing a single tiny
star incidentally the James web
equipment is capable of observing not
only single objects tucked away in the
depths of space but tremendous space
structures as well that stretch for
hundreds of light
years one of them is the Kina nebula
which is one of the largest Stellar
nurseries in our galaxy this bright and
vast cluster is located about
8,500 light years from the earth and has
a mass of up to 900,000
Suns it contains not only giant clouds
of interstellar gas and dust but also
thousands of stars from the smallest
ones to the most
gigantic this is where two of the Milky
Way's brightest objects are
located EA karini and
wr25 the Luminosity of each is several
million times greater than that of the
sun unique objects like that certainly
attract astronomer's attention besides
James web's infrared cameras are able to
pick out great numbers of stars in the
dusty Haze which were previously unknown
to us the point is that it is in this
area in space that hundreds of young
stars are constantly getting
born according to Modern Concepts new
stars are formed by gravitational forces
that compress and heat up clouds of
cosmic
dust during its evolutionary process a
protestar goes through several stages
until finally a thermonuclear reaction
kicks in in its interior this theory has
been confirmed by multiple observations
but many details of this long and
complex process currently Remain
understudied the formation of a new star
sometimes takes millions of years but
astronomers don't need that long to
observe it thanks to James web's
infrared senses thousands of protestas
and young stars at various stages of
evolution have been detected in the Ina
nebula it is important to note that all
these objects formed within the same gas
cloud which means that they're very
similar in terms of composition and age
by observing them researchers can fully
trace the process of star
formation and better understand what
forces are
involved some phases of this process
predicted only in theory take hours or
days and with James web the chance of
capturing them is greatly enhanced
for all we know we may soon be able to
admire a photo of a young star flaring
up thousands of light years from the
Sun meanwhile an 18 section mirror 6 and
1/2 m in diameter and an onboard array
of high accuracy instruments allowed
James web to capture light from objects
much further away at the very edge of
the visible
Universe they're more than 13 billion
years old
giving us a glimpse of the earliest
times immediately after the hypothetical
Big
Bang however even James web would not
have been able to see their luminescence
but for one unique
coincidence the phenomenon of
gravitational lensing has long been
known to scientists this physical
phenomenon helps us to better see into
the depths of the universe and this is
how it works a powerful gravity
generated by massive body focuses and
amplifies light from a source behind it
such an effect can be produced only on
condition that a great many factors
happily combine so it is not surprising
that it is one of the rarest phenomena
in the universe it is all the more
surprising that while observing the
Galaxy cluster SMX 0723 located about 4
billion light years from the earth James
web captured light of a space object
passing through gravitational lenses as
many as three
times in total the radiation was
Amplified about 20 times without which
astronomers would hardly have been able
to distinguish it from background
noise the object is thought to be a
distant and very old Galaxy whose age is
estimated to be 13 billion
years about 10 other star clusters have
also been detected which are thought to
have originated between 200 and 700
million years after the Genesis of the
universe according to some observations
they have a complex structure which
takes tens of millions of years to
form this discovery will allow
scientists to develop the existing ideas
about the early stages of the universe's
Evolution and may even prompt to
question its
age unfortunately we still know very
little about such remote times and James
web will surely help us learn more about
them
exoplanets differ very much in terms of
their environment their Dimensions may
be enormous some even beating Jupiter
but there are also comparatively smaller
ones close to our Earth in size some of
these bodies are hot consumed with
oceans of mol and lava whereas others
are encased in a shell of permanent ice
there are planets out there made
entirely of oceans with not a bit of dry
land on them while in others sulfuric
acid drains or Diamond snow are a
regular
occurrence various techniques are used
for discovering other worlds as a rule
it is next to impossible to spot an
exoplanet by simply looking through a
telescope that is why in 2009 Kepler was
launched the first Space Telescope
designed for searching for planets
beyond the boundaries of the solar
system the telescope's cameras had 42
charge coupled devices or ccds with a
total resolution of around 96
megapixels with a field of view covering
about 25% of the sky and coupled with a
1 and a/2 M mirror of the telescope it
was able to detect astronomical bodies
within 3,000 light years from the earth
in the 3 and 1 half years of productive
operations Kepler managed to spot over 3
and a half th000 exoplanet candidates
the status of over 2,000 of these has
already been confirmed by repeated
observations it was in this period that
the smallest of known exoplanets today
was detected the diameter of Kepler 37b
is just
35.7% that of the Earth the telescope
was also instrumental in registering
several stars and brown
dwarves the transit method was used by
Kepler in the search for exoplanets this
method is based on observing the Stars
Luminosity if the supposed Planet passes
between the parent star and the Observer
this will be noticed in The Telltale
decrease in the Stars Luminosity the
extent of these fluctuations in
Luminosity directly depends on the ratio
of the stars and planets Dimensions
while their regularity allows one to
estimate the object's orbital period the
transit method requires accuracy in
measurements changes in a star's
Spectrum account for less than 2% and a
usually usually tenths or even hundreds
of 1% ripples in the atmosphere dust and
precipitations negatively affect results
produced by earth-based
telescopes that is the reason why
telescopes based on automatic space
stations are used for searching for
objects beyond the boundaries of the
solar
system unfortunately in 2013 3 and 1
half years into the mission the Kepler
space telescope had several major
equipment failures in 2018 the
spacecraft ended science operations
completely Kepler was the first
spacecraft to be created specifically
for looking for
exoplanets however most of the objects
it managed to spot happened to be too
remot and dim to study them in any
satisfying detail that is why the next
space research complex had slightly
different parameters Kepler was
succeeded by the test Telescope launched
by NASA on the 18th of April ail
2018 its main object was searching for
Rocky exoplanets orbiting the brightest
stars within 200 light years from the
Sun this telescope also used the transit
method and here is the spacecraft's
brief profile Tess is equipped with four
refractors with a 24x 24° field of view
and a 10 cm aperture The spacecraft's
Peculiar orbit allows it to cover both
the northern and the southern parts of
the sky which is approximately 85% of
the entire Sky photos are taken by four
cameras and the resolution of each
camera's CCD is 16.8
megapixels toi700d is one of the most
notable objects discovered by
Tess this exoplanet became the first
object of the kind comparable to the
Earth and size and which found itself in
the habitable zone with star it orbits
DOI 700 a red dwarf lying slightly over
a 100 light years away from the Sun it
is a small and rather cold star its
temperature is half that of the Sun and
its mass and radius are just 40% those
of the sun DOI 700 is peculiar for its
high stability not a single flare has
been registered on it since the
beginning of
observations a Stars stability is a
positive feature because births activity
are able to divver its planets of their
atmospheres and be generally pernicious
for potential life on planet
surfaces there are at least three
planets orbiting toi 700 the one closest
to it toi
700b is comparable to the Earth in size
its mass is approximately 1.07 times
that of our planet and its radius
differs from that of the Earth by not
more than 2% unfortunately to I 700b is
too close to its host star it is within
about 06 astronomical units and a year
on the planet lasts just 10 days in
addition to that chances are it is
tidily locked that is it faces the star
with one in the same side this means
that the planet is likely to be
scorching hot the planet lying further
from its star toi 700 C is thought to be
a mini Neptune its mass may be from 5 to
13 times that of our earth and its
radius is two or three times that of the
earth it takes DOI 700c 16 days to
complete one orbit around its host Star
located closer to the star than the
inner border of the habitable zone it
must be too hot for life to originate
and evolve there toi700d is the third
and at this point the remotest planet in
the system discovered by now it takes
37.4 days to complete a full orbit which
by the way lies along the inner edge of
the habitable zone the mass of toi700d
hasn't been gauged precisely and may be
anything from 1 to three times that of
the Earth at the same time the planet's
radius is just 20 to 30% bigger than
that of the earth toi700d is thought to
be a rocky world but its exact
composition is not yet known the amount
of energy received by the planet from
its star is 86% that of the amount we
receive from the Sun assuming the
planet's atmosphere is similar to ours
the steady state temperature on the
surface of toi700d is estimated at
268.2 K or 4.3 de C below 0 however due
to the greenhouse effect or other
features of the atmosphere we may not
know yet this figure May shift either up
or down there is no precise data on the
eccentricity of toi700d but it is
thought to be small at
around1 as the planet's orbit finds
itself at the inner edge of the
goldilock Zone the planet's eccentricity
however small May incidentally turn out
to be perceptible when the planet comes
too close to its star from time to time
thus actually leaving the habitable zone
still with a year on the planet lasting
slightly over one Earth month such
unfavorable periods are expected to be
rather short if there are living
creatures on toi700d
then they might be able to weather the
harsh spells in a state of
antibiosis alternatively they could
adapt or migrate to less inclement areas
even though the data acquired by
spectral analysis of toi700d can't be
enough for making conclusions there is a
chance that there is liquid water on the
planet's surface then there is is bound
to be the greenhouse effect to which
will help the surface temperature to
reach favorable values as I've already
mentioned toi700d along with the other
known planets in the system is highly
likely to be tidily locked to its star
if this is the case there should be a
stark difference in temperatures between
the sunny side and the shadow side this
contrast could be leveled off by dense
atmosphere but that would cause powerful
hurricane
winds although the main mission of Tess
has been accomplished by now it still
has enough resources to carry on
operations the telescope will continue
taking snapshots of the sky including
the Milky Way plane which is the most
challenging direction for
observation over
2,100 exoplanet candidates have been
discovered by Tess in the course of the
main mission not less than 66 of them
have already been
confirmed apart from that six supern noi
flares have been registered three
exocomets identified and a great number
of photos taken of small bodies in the
solar system the latters were not
objects of the main mission but are of
course of scientific
interest shortly before Halloween in
2020 NASA compiled a list of the most
terrifying worlds among others they
included six EXO
planets each of these objects
environments is not just extremely harsh
for any living organism even finding
oneself in their comparatively close
proximity may prove to be fatal the
first object on the list is a black gas
giant designation
dr2b this celestial object orbits the
star
tr2 which is a yellow dwarf lying as far
as 718 light years away from us let's
take a close closer look at
it due to some unique properties of the
chemical composition of the surface of
dr2b the planet absorbs over 99% of all
the light shed on it the nature of these
properties remains a mystery and chances
are there are some chemical reactions
taking place on the surface that we have
never registered on any similar object
before and it is these properties that
make tres to be the darkest exoplanet on
the astronomical map of today
this gas giant was discovered on the
21st of August 2006 with more details on
its characteristics obtained several
years
later the mass of t2b is 1.2 Jupiter
masses and its radius measures 1.27
times that of
Jupiter the atmosphere is as scorching
as 1,000° Celsius which gives the
exoplanet a faint red glow like that of
ambers
still in spite of its gloomy looks dr2b
doesn't really qualify to be called the
most dangerous place in the universe
there are many more objects lurking in
space that are more terrifying than that
let's see some more inhospitable
ones here is another exoplanet
designation 55 canri e it lies in the
system of a sunlike star designation 55
canri a this Cal object was discovered
on the 30th of August 2004 by the
Doppler spectroscopy method let's look
at it in more detail the planet's mass
equals approximately eight Earth masses
and its radius measures
1.875 that of the
earth 55 canre e is tidily locked and so
it is always daytime on one side and
night time on the other that is why the
side facing the host star is always
heated up to a temperature reach in 2,
400° C with a temperature on the night
side
1300°
C these values are so high because the
distance between the planet and its
parent star is just
0183 astronomical
units besides volcanism on 55 canre e
which is thought likely to be there
causes dust clouds emissions these
clouds trap heat and effectively prevent
it from escaping into
space the planet's orbital period is
slightly under 18 hours as for the
atmospherical makeup there is helium and
hydrogen registered in it there are also
large amounts of carbon incidentally
this element is likely to form thick
layers of graphite and diamonds in the
planet's
interior 55 canri e isn't the only
object in the planetary system of its
host star there are four other celestial
objects objects orbiting it the
environments on these are by far more
hospitable which is the feature by which
the 55 canre a system differs from the
following
object it is dubbed pist or PSR 1257
plus
12C this is an exoplanet lying in a
pulsar system the celestial object is
located just
.36 astronomical units from the system
center this shows that pist wouldn't
have survived a supernova that must have
taken place before the Pulsar had been
formed consequently the exoplanet is
likely to have formed after this
tremendous event with the material for
it coming from the nebula left after the
explosion according to another
hypothesis the Pulsar may have formed
after the merging of two white dwarves
unlike with a supernova this process
isn't always accompanied by a powerful
blast still as this is the first object
of its kind we have discovered science
cannot give a definite answer as to its
Origins the system with a celestial
object lies
2,300 light years from the earth its
mass is approximately four times that of
our planet as for its orbital period it
is around 66 days incidentally the
outstandingly powerful radiation emitted
by the Pulsa is enough to crumple any
spaceship wanting to approach the
mysterious exoplanet in its
system even with all these properties
taken into account pist does not really
qualify as the most dangerous exoplanet
known to us on approaching it an
astronomical body May simply get
destroyed but it would get positively
vaporized in close proximity to the
following
object the reason for this effect is the
extremely high temperature on Kepler 7
70b which is the hottest exoplanet known
to us the object orbits the subdwarf
star Kepler 70 with a surface
temperature higher than that on our sun
it reaches
6,800 de C the object's Mass equals 0.44
Earth masses and its radius measures
0.76 that of the
Earth the celestial object's orbital
period is
345 minutes
in other words a day here is less than 6
hours long interestingly the exoplanet
regularly passes another object in the
system Kepler 70c at a distance of
240,000
KM to date this is the closest that
planets in space have been registered to
pass each
other the extremely high temperature on
Kepler 70b could be accounted for by the
fact that this object May once have been
part of its parents St Star as for
giving it the status of an exoplanet it
will take more evidence to confirm that
it deserves to be given it so this
remains an open
question it should be mentioned that
Kepler 70b is not the only celestial
object we know of that interacts with
its parent star so
closely another object in similar
conditions is the exoplanet known as
wasp
12b this Celestial body lies 87 L years
away from our system its radius measures
1.93 times that of Jupiter and its mass
equals 1.46 Jupiter masses wasp 12b is
just 03 astronomical units away from its
parent star due to this close proximity
the exoplanet has a temperature reaching
as much as 2,200 de C the host star's
extremely powerful gravitation slowly
absorbs wasp 12 be eventually in
approximately 10 million years time the
exoplanet is expected to be destroyed
completely bearing all this in mind we
will probably never delve any deeper
into the nature of this exoplanet it
would appear that studying worlds of
this kind cannot be high on scientists
list of
priorities however some of these objects
may happen to have some really unique
features seemingly quite plain and
ordinary well like that may conceal many
more dangers than would appear at first
glance when flying past the celestial
body
hd189733b for example one might
complacently think it a safe Planet as
it resembles our Earth by its
looks but if one were to get as low as
the level of its atmosphere one would be
exposed to some life-threatening
dangers for a start the object's winds
carry particles of silicate and develop
velocities of
8,700
kmph besides the rains on this planet
cause precipitations of M and
glass the reasons for such hazardous
weather conditions are extremely high
temperatures and the atmosphere's
peculiar chemical composition speaking
about the exoplanet's orbital period it
is approximately 2.5 days and it is
highly likely that the object is tidily
locked to its parent
Star as usual a quick overview of its
main
characteristics
hd189733b is a bright blue gas giant
orbiting an orange dwarf in the
constellation vula it lies just 63 light
years away from our system the object's
diameter is 1.1 times that of Jupiter
and as for its mass it is
113% that of
Jupiter interesting inly the distance
between hd189733b and its star is 30
times less than the distance between the
Earth and the Sun and equals
approximately 5 million
km due to its close proximity to the
parent star it has a constant surface
temperature of as high as around 930 de
C on the day side with the temperature
on the night side never dropping below
425°
C immediately on being discovered the
celestial body became a subject of
Investigations in 2007 thanks to data
obtained by the Hubble telescope
scientists found out that hd189733b has
a foggy
atmosphere interestingly when the planet
transits between the Observer on the
earth and its star its atmosphere
assumes a reddish Hue this effect could
possibly be caused by the haze in the
atmosphere according to preliminary
estimates it consists of particles of
iron silicates and aluminium
oxide apart from that the information
beamed back by the Hubble telescope
helped scientists establish that the
planet's atmosphere contains water vapor
neutral oxygen and an organic methane
compound additional investigations
revealed the presence of carbon monoxide
on the day side of the planet what
prompted most questions however was the
results of Investigations revealing
traces of methane of an unusual Variety
in the planet's atmosphere this chemical
element was shown to be in a peculiar
fluorescent State when it emits
electromagnetic radiation in the
infrared range this state of the
substance is indicative of some unknown
activity in the atmosphere of the
exoplanet which Still Remains to be
found
out this is quite a clear-cut example of
a situation when investigating an object
like an exoplanet with an exceptionally
harsh environment May yield unexpected
results about some processes taking
place there that will be a valuable
contribution to science and as the
process of studying these worlds
continues they will remain no other than
horror planets to us as well as a solid
reminder that we're more than just lucky
to be the Dwellers of our
[Music]
Earth the first steps in theoretical
confirmation of there being ocean worlds
out there that is planets fully covered
in water were made back in the
1970s that is when evidence was found
that radioactive decay in a planet's
interior and tidal forces may cause
water ice to melt and subsequently form
huge
oceans in all likelihood similar
processes take place on Jupiter's and
Saturn's
satellites however these celestial
bodies remain icebound as they lie too
far away from the Sun whose Rays would
otherwise melt the thick layers of ice
but when we talk about an ocean planet a
slightly different type of space objects
is meant the term implies that the ocean
on a planet's surface isn't concealed
under a layer of ice and its depth
measures more than 100 km theoretical
calculations of these planets formation
and evolution processes were carried out
in 2004 by French astrophysicists headed
by Kristoph Satan according to this
theory if the mass of a forming planet
is more than 10 times that of the Earth
this starts to actively attract hydrogen
and helium from the gas and dust cloud
around it in this manner with time it
grows into a gas
giant by contrast if this planet's mass
is just 6 to8 Earth masses the new
planet is going to be comprised of ice
and rocks roughly in equal measure just
to compare the mass total of all water
in the global ocean on our Earth
accounts for just
0.025% % of the Earth's total
mass in this case provided a space
object's orbit lies far from the host
star this object is going to be either
an ice giant or a cold superar
radioactive decay taking place inside
the core will help melt some portion of
the ice which in its turn will help form
a subsurface ocean where the planet's
outer layers will still remain Frozen if
the planet happens to find itself in its
Stars habitable Z Zone its outer layers
will melt and spill all over the surface
in a boundless ocean theoretical
calculations show that a planet with a
mass 6 to 8 times down of the earth may
have a layer of water over 100 km thick
the pressure exerted by this amount of
water May reach 20,000 atmospheres
depending on temperature impurities and
other parameters this is enough for some
special exotic varieties of ice to form
like one's remaining solid even at high
temperatures in addition unlike the
familiar water ice these modifications
would be heavier than liquid water for
example the density of ice 7 which is
likely to form in these conditions
should be around
1,650 kilos per cubic meter this ice
settles on the planet's Ocean's bottom
and forms a massive cryosphere that
envelops the more massive
core the opportunity to put these
theoretical assumptions to test arose
when a tiny and dim star was spotted 42
light years away from the earth it was
dubbed GLA
1214 the diameter of this red dwarf
turned out to be five times smaller than
that of the sun with its mass just
15.7% that of the Sun at the same time
GLA 124 is 300 times dimmer than our
parent star while its surface
temperature is only 3,000 kin or
2,700 there is nothing particularly
remarkable about the star itself to be
blunt it is just another nondescript Red
Dwarf that looks like any of the
billions of other stars in our
galaxy however in 2009 a solitary planet
was detected in its environs which was
dubbed glea
1214b with its diameter measuring 2 and
1/2 times that of the Earth this
exoplanet is just 6 and 1 half times
heavier than our home planet
straightforward calculations show the
freefall acceleration on the exoplanet
surface to be just 91% that of the Earth
the average density of glea 1214b is
approximately
1,870 kilos per cubic
M judging by this comparatively small
value the exoplanet cannot realistically
be made up of mostly metals and rocks as
is the case with our Earth for example
but incidentally this average density
value seems to confirm the assumption
that the astronomical body is 75% water
or water rice and just 25% TRS thus it
appears safe to suggest that this
exoplanet is an ocean
planet the object lies very close to its
host star the average distance between
them measures just around 2 million km
or 014 astronomical units which is 75
times smaller than that between the
Earth and the
Sun Also the orbit eccentricity is
rather high at 27 slightly more than
that of
Pluto this means that in its perhelion
glya 1214b is approximately twice as
close to its star than when in its
aelon as for its orbital period it takes
the planet about 36 hours to complete
it the red dwarf gleer 1214 may be 300
times dimmer than the Sun but this
incredible proximity to the star makes
the climate on glyer 1214b scorching hot
supposing the reflection coefficient of
the surface of glyer 1214b is the same
as that of Venus the planet's surface
temperature is supposed to be around
393 K or
120°
C if on the other hand the surface is
darker the temperature May reach as much
as 553 kin or
280° C due to the fact that the orbit of
glea 1214b crosses the Stars disc
scientists are able to carry out
spectroscopic investigations of its
atmosphere still the results are rather
ambiguous if this space object really is
an ocean planet its atmosphere is
supposed to predominantly consist of
water vapor with some accompanying gases
interestingly no lines of hydrogen
helium or complex substances like water
CO2 and ammonia have so far been
detected in the planet Spectrum it is
thought that the outer layer of the
dense atmosphere conceals its true
content from The
Observer the conditions on the surface
of gisa 1214b remind one of what it is
like inside a giant steam boiler
interestingly the atmospheric pressure
in its lowest strata should be at least
15 Tons as high as that of the earth as
the ocean and the atmosphere are in a
state of thermodynamic equilibrium the
border between them is rather blurred no
wonder as the density of water vapor
just above the ocean's surface is
practically equal to that of constantly
boiling water as we look deeper at the
lowest Strat of the ocean the pressure
will continue to increase until we reach
the depth of 100 km with a pressure
value at this depth water will be
enabled to remain in its liquid state
even at temperatures this high and so we
will see the bottom made up of dense and
heavy ice whose thickness is estimated
to be upwards of 5,000
km thus most water on the planet is
concentrated here below the cryosphere
there should be the core made up of
rocks and
metals unfortunately chances of Life
evolving on any ocean planet are rather
thin even if the surface temp
temperature happens to be more favorable
than on this one this is so due to the
fact that oceans on planets like that
too poor in terms of micro elements that
are vital for living
creatures even taking into account
meteorites that occasionally bombard the
surfaces of these celestial bodies the
chemical diversity is simply not good
enough for life to originate
here still studying ocean planets poses
a great scientific interest
according to NASA's mathematical
modeling estimates published in 2020
there may be billions of planets of this
type in our galaxy both cold harboring
an ocean under an ice shell and warm
like gisa
1214b water is one of the most
widespread complex chemical compounds in
the universe and this means that the
chances of discovering new ocean planets
are quite
optimistic
there is a giant cloud in space hundreds
of light years away from the earth with
some of its areas concealing dozens of
yet unborn Stars others are ripped apart
by tremendous
flashes the space here is permeated by
lethal ionizing radiation and threads of
red hot hydrogen and fiery vortices are
capable of absorbing whole Stellar
systems this is where stars are Bor born
the Stellar Nursery Which is closest to
the
earth what does it conceal from
[Music]
us there are Stellar nurseries richly
scattered across the Galaxy with some of
them comparatively modest in size others
stretch for tens and even hundreds of
light years these are vast nebuli made
up of interstellar gas and dust being
inexorably compressed by gravity forces
most of these tremendous clouds are
barely visible against the abyss of
space but some of them can be seen from
the earth with a naked
eye one of these structures is the Orion
Nebula located
1,344 light years away from the earth it
is the middle object in the so-called
sword of Orion a clearly visible line
produced by three relatively bright
light sources due to its large size and
comparative closeness to the Earth the
nebula has been attractive for
scientists ever since the early days of
astronomy it is hardly surprising
therefore that this great structure is
one of the best studied space
objects it was the Hubble orbital Space
Telescope that beamed back first images
of the Orion Nebula back in
1993 where the rich diversity of its
colors can be
appreciated most of the material was of
a reddish or bluish purple Hue while
unusual bright green lines of some
peripheral areas were revealed by
spectral analysis this phenomenon
perplexed scientists for a long time as
the observed radiation did not
demonstrate any chemical element known
at the time there was even a hypothesis
that was put forward by there being a
hypothetical element nebulium argued to
be not present on our Planet but
allegedly amply scattered across clouds
and
space however with the advancement of
science it turned out that the light was
emitted by extremely rarified and
ionized oxygen this discovery accounted
not only for the bizarre illumination of
many nebula including our
sun there are currently not less than
3,000 stars discovered in the Orion
Nebula to date as well as giant clouds
of interstellar gas and a great number
of protestant
all this amazing diversity of space
objects is concentrated in an area of
around 23 Li and diameter all of them
continuously and elaborately interacting
with each other the overall mass of the
material concentrated here is around
10,000 solar
masses looking at the Orion Nebula
closer we will notice several clearly
defined areas the most outstanding of
them is trapezium also known as Theta
one
orionis it's an open star cluster about
300,000 years of age made up of eight
main
components some of them are binary Stars
others have no
companions the brightest and most
noticeable of the trapezium stars are
four Stellar systems designated by
letters of the Latin
alphabet located close to each other
they lie within an area about 1 and a
half light years in
diameter each of these object object's
mass is within 15 to 40 solar masses
which means that these stars are quite
young and hot Theta 1 orionis sea is the
most massive as well as the brightest
star in both the trapezium cluster and
actually the entire nebula it is a white
and blue main sequence star with a mass
roughly 40 solar masses whose radius is
8 times out of the Sun the object's
surface temperature is approximately
45,000 Kelvin
and its Luminosity about
250,000 times higher than that of the
Sun the radiation of theta 1 oronia C
illumines virtually all the nebula
around it but there is hardly any
Interstellar gas in its immediate
vicinity this is the case due to the
fact it is typical for objects of this
class to experience exceptionally
powerful Stellar Wind that scatters
rarified material far
off having traveled a few few light
years away from trapezium we will see
another remarkable system which is Theta
orionis it is made up of three
gravitationally bound stars located
close to the so-called Orion bar an
extensive feature of hot gas emitting
bright light it was impossible to study
this area for a long time on account of
dense clouds of dust and thanks to the
James web telescope more detailed images
of this region have been beamed back to
us the first component of theta 2
orionis is just slightly less massive
and not as luminous as the trapeziums
biggest star as for its surface
temperature it measures about 35,000 K
the second component of the system is 15
times as massive as the sun and 12,000
times as bright the third component is
as heavy as five solar masses and its
temperature almost reaches 14,000 kin
however it wasn't just Bright Stars that
CAU the research's attention James web's
infrared cameras allowed it to detect
previously unseen objects hidden deep
within the clouds of gas and dust thanks
to the telescope about 180 so-called
props have been discovered at the heart
of the Orion Nebula these are dense dark
protoplanetary discs surrounding stars
that are still in the process of
formation one of these is Orion
29468 6 a young protesta about 1 million
years old surrounded by a gas and dust
disc about 300 astronomical units in
diameter thanks to its being air John to
Earth we can observe its structure and
size it is expected to hid the main
sequence phase in a few million years
and it will be accompanied by a system
of several exoplanets and possibly their
satellites the night sky of these future
celestial bodies be a truly fantastic
sight just imagine a multicolored
luminous veil with the glow of a
multitude of close and bright stars far
more numerous than those seen from the
earth coming through and now and then
tremendous swirls of glowing gas cover
half the sky turning the night into
translucent
Twilight if we fly a little further and
examine the wider region we see that the
bulk of the ne NE is filled with
scattered gas the central part of the
cloud is filled with highly ionized
hydrogen which actively absorbs high
energy Stellar
radiation the temperature of this gas
can reach 10,000 Kelvin but it falls
sharply towards the edge of the region
temperature and pressure contrasts as
well as the Collision of Stellar Wind
streams set material in space in motion
creating tremendous currents and
vortices according to calcul ations some
of them can reach speeds of up to 50
km/s and their size can be greater than
the solar
system also in some areas of the nebula
thin strands stretching for several
light years have been detected
consisting of relatively cool molecular
hydrogen without mixtures of methane
ethane and
water further out we will see that the
central region of the Orion Nebula is
enveloped in a vast cloud of cooler
denser
gas The Cloud of bright stars and the
luminescence of ionized hydrogen
intricately intertwine here creating a
beautiful multicolored curtain of
light hidden behind it are hundreds of
space objects invisible in the optical
range but the infrared cameras of
today's telescopes allow us to see
through the veil of interstellar
matter by combining data from different
sources astronomers have discovered
about 700 Proto stars at different
stages of evolution within this region
their concentration is noticeably lower
than in the central part of the nebula
due to the lower degree of gravitational
compression of the interstellar gas the
absolute majority of these objects are
very young by space standards and are
still in the process of
formation according to Modern concepts
of Stellar evolution new stars form
during gradual gravitational compression
of large clouds of interstellar gas
typically as a result of this process
giant nebula split up into a number of
closely grouped gravity centers which
soon turn into
protostars such clusters are called
Stellar nurseries or more scientifically
regions of star
formation at a certain point the
internal pressure of the compressed gas
compensates for the gravitational forces
bringing the protestar to a state of
temporary
equilibrium the remaining material
swirls into a giant Vortex disc with
some of it gradually absorbed by the
future star and the rest of it by
contrast expelled far beyond the
boundaries of the nassin system the
growing magnetic field of the young star
also plays its part as ionized particles
accelerate through its field lines and
then rapidly escape from the vicinity of
the object it has been calculated that
such flows can reach speeds of up to
several hundred km m/
second as they collide with the gas
clouds surrounding them they create
large scale vortices and hemispheres
called herbig Harrow
objects in the process part of the
kinetic energy dissipates into light and
heat giving these bizarre structures
different
colors in addition the ultra fast motion
affects the surrounding material
spreading shock waves across it which
incidentally are also captured by
telescopes since Stellar nurseries
contain many closely spaced protostars
each producing several gas emissions it
is not surprising that herbig har
objects exhibit an amazing variety of
shapes and colors clearly being
essentially the result of a major Cosmic
Collision they're highly unstable and
variable herbig Harrow objects rapidly
change color and shape and typically
disperse completely over several tens of
thousands of
years during this time they cover
between one and three light years on an
escape trajectory from their parent
Stars about 400 such objects have been
discovered so far with their total
number within the Milky Way estimated to
be about
150,000 perhaps one of the varieties of
this all inspiring natural phenomenon is
the bullets hundreds of astronomical
units in diameter also detected in the
Orion Nebula moving at incredible speeds
they easily Pierce thinner hydrogen
clouds creating far flung shock waves in
them according to spectral analysis the
frontal parts of these objects contain
atoms of iron that glow in the infrared
the bullets are estimated to be about a
thousand years old and their origin is
still a mystery they supposedly
originated from some catastrophic
event moving on we will soon find that
the Orion Nebula is part of a much
larger Cosmic structure called the Orion
Cloud it stretches for hundreds of light
years accounting for virtually the
entire constellation of Orion in the
earth's night
sky this is where the well-known HSE
head nebula is located remarkable for
its bizarre shape it is a dense dust
cloud about 3 and 1 half L years in
diameter clearly visible against
background of a contrasting scarid glow
also close to the Orion Nebula there is
an impressive Cosmic structure called
the B Loop this emission nebula about
300 light years in size came into being
about 3 million years ago after a series
of consecutive explosions of mutually
close
Supernova after the shock compressed gas
jets mixed together they produced a
gigantic curved nebula and the glow of
several young Stars gathered in an open
cluster made it reddish in
Hue for all its beauty the Orion Nebula
is is a fragile and unstable object by
the universe's standards Stellar winds
and pressure of light from many young
stars as well as gas emissions and
turbulent vortices constantly disperse
its material in the surrounding space
the nebula has already lost about 60% of
its original material and in about
100,000 years it will be stripped of its
remnants in place of the shiny
multicolored Cloud there will remain an
open star cluster similar to the
lies for a Time the young Stars forming
it will move together but eventually
each will find its separate way through
the vast expanse of the boundless Galaxy
around first stop is 202 light years
away from the earth destination K2
d141 an orange dwarf its mass is is
roughly 7 that of the Sun and its radius
measures 68% that of our host star with
these parameters almost perfectly
proportional the star's temperature
reaches
4,600 Kelvin which is about 20% less
than that of the Sun and now to the
planet in question just 007 astronomical
units away from its star there lies a
really bizarre world designation K2 Das
141b this Rocky exoplanet is five times
as massive as the Earth with its radius
1.5 times as big as that of our Earth
all this gives us grounds to assume that
the gravity on the planet's surface is
at least twice as strongest that on our
planet the heavy metallic core meanwhile
accounts for 20 to 50% of the planet's
overall Mass it takes the celestial body
about 6 and 1 half hours to complete a
full orbit around its parent star being
extremely close it is tidily locked to
it that is it faces the star with one in
the same side at all times observations
show that the temperature on the
planet's day side reaches
3,270 K or 3000°
C this is enough not only to melt most
strs and metals but also to effectively
evaporate them the day side of the
planet is assumed to be covered with a
lava ocean that never ceases to boil the
atmosphere is thought to be rather
exotic made up of steams of heavy metals
and silicates by contrast the planet's
night side is incredibly freezing
according to estimates the temperature
of most of its area is tens of times
lower than that on the day side and on
balance its values are supposed to be
Subzero mathematical modeling shows that
this sharp temperature contrast gives
rise to exceptionally strong winds whose
speed reaches 1.75
km/s this is roughly five times the
speed of sound which means that the
surface of k2-11 141b is continuously
shaken by exceptionally powerful
deafening
rumbling it is assumed that on reaching
the night side atmospheric streams
condense and precipitate on its surface
in the form of fiery rain this forms
lava rivers and eventually this melt and
Metal makes its way back into a magma
ocean to evaporate again later on and to
continue this incredible fiery
circulation however this infernal cycle
affects only a relatively small part of
the planet's night side the thing is
that masses of evaporated elements from
the day side simply don't make it to the
main part of the night side and
precipitate somewhere on the border that
is why the central part of the night
side is likely to be a freezing desert
bound with lay s of solid
rocks remarkably k2-11 141b is far from
being the hottest planet that we know of
for example there is an object referred
to as kelt 9B lying 670 Li years away
from the earth its surface is as hot as
4,6 Kelvin which is approximately
4,330 de C
just to compare the outer layers of
almost all red dwarves for example are
much cooler which means that in terms of
temperature this exoplanet is quite a
match to
Stars its parent star designation K 9 is
of a whitish blue color and has a mass
2.6 times that of the Sun as for its
diameter it is 2.3 times that of our
star the surface temperature of count 9
is rather high at approxim oim
10,170 k or a staggering
99,900 de C this largely accounts for
the extreme conditions on count 9B which
lies quite close
by just
035 astronomical units away from its
parent star the planet completes a full
orbit around its system center roughly
every 1 and a half
days C 9B is a hot gas giant compar
comped to Jupiter its mass is 2.8 times
as big and its radius measures roughly
twice as much as that of the largest
planet in our system based on today's
Notions about the composition of this
type of planets the inner part of K 9
B's atmosphere is supposed to be even
hotter estimates allow for this value to
reach as much as 11,000 Kelvin on
account of heavy metal
ionization with this figure so
exceptionally big it appears that the
planet atmosphere should contain
vaporized ion and titanium alongside the
elements were're used to in an
atmosphere's composition such as
hydrogen or helium its close proximity
to the parent star and the extremely
high temperature cause the planet to
gradually lose its atmosphere by and by
powerful Stellar Wind Blows it off into
space which is why the object is
shrouded in a cloud of rarified gas this
material will eventually be attracted
and absorbed by the star
interestingly According to some
estimates the exoplanet loses up to 68
Earth masses every billion years
theoretically in a long while kelt 9B
May well get stripped of all of its
atmosphere and transform itself into a
thian planet however its parent star is
likely to hit the final stage of its
life cycle long before that swallowing
up and destroying all the celestial
objects within its
reach
the space objects we have just looked at
are a living proof as it were of the
fact that stars can destroy the planets
close to them and not just warm them up
but incidentally there are celestial
objects out there in the universe that
have experienced their parent stars
wroth in full measure one of such
objects lies
4,570 light years away from the earth in
the environs of a small star designation
v391 pegasi now the star is a white
dwarf whose mass is twice as little as
that of the Sun and whose radius is
approximately 23% that of our parent
star the temperature of the celestial
object is unbelievably high at almost
30,000 Kelvin all thermonuclear
reactions in its interior would have run
their course a long while ago up ahead
are hundreds of billions of years of
slow cooling with the white dwarf
eventually transforming into a black one
the planets we will look look at
referred to as v391 Pegasi b is in this
ordinary Stars environs its lot is
exceptionally amazing according to
mathematical modeling the planet not
only survived its progenitor star
shedding its outer layers but actually
found itself almost within the star for
some time it is assumed that when the
systems star v391 pegasi transformed
into a red giant its outer layers
extremely rarified by then were almost
brushing the planet's orbit their
density became dozens of times lower
than the atmospheric Airway used to
which means that the celestial objects
devoured by the dying star remained
whole for a while and didn't get
destroyed at once it goes without saying
that they would have been losing their
speed and dropped into the Stars hotter
and denser layers still v391 pegasi shed
its outer layers sooner than v391 Pegasi
b melted and ceased to exist as a whole
object at the moment the exoplanet
appears to be a gas giant three times as
massive as Jupiter its orbit passes 1.7
astronomical units away from its parent
star and it takes the planet
approximately
1,170 Earth days to complete a full
orbit around its system center it is
still not entirely clear how this
astronomical body managed to preserve
such a big Mass after its collision with
a scorching heart layers of the star
their influence was supposed to have
destroyed the object's atmosphere
completely however there is no doubt
that the host Stars collapse brought
about some dramatic changes both in
terms of the exoplanet's orbit and its
parameters that is why it is hardly
possible for us to ever find out what
v391 Pegasi b was like before immersing
in a sea of raging
plasma space expanses conceal
uncountable astronomical objects with
the most bizarre properties some of them
are almost totally invisible through
regular telescopes but can be detected
by looking at Radio wavelengths when
exploring space an example of such like
celestial objects is Pulsar neutron
stars spinning on their rexes at a
mindboggling speed these object Spectra
are peculiar for exceptionally fast and
regular pulsations that is why it is
quite easy to detect another celestial
body transiting between a radiation
Source like that and an observer on the
earth this is precisely the way our next
object of Interest was discovered but
first we'll be looking at a Pulsa which
lies around 4,000 light years away from
the earth this neutron star boasts quite
a long name here it is on the screen and
now let's check out its remarkable
features the pulsar's diameter is just a
measly 20 km and its mass is
approximately 1.4 that of the Sun the
object spins at an incredible rate with
roughly 10,000 rotations a minute while
continuously emitting powerful
electromagnetic radiation impulses now
the surface of the exoplanet our next
object of interest is continuously
exposed to these waves of lethal
radiation which makes it a hostile and
forbidding
place it takes this planet just 2 hours
to complete a full orbit around its
system center and the distance to the
Pulsa is smaller than the sun's radius
just 600,000 km or 004 astronomical
units incidentally the celestial body's
surface is bound by Eternal code in
space as its parent star just barely
emits thermal energy the object's mass
is around 330 that of the earth while
its radius is four times that of our
planet this makes gravity on its surface
as much as 20 times stronger than on the
Earth
estimates show the planet's average
density to be about 23 g per cubic cm
which is more than most chemical
compounds we know the planet is thought
to be made up for the most part of
crystallized carbon under a lot of
pressure besides the object's upper
layers contain some oxygen which is
probably chemically bound with carbon it
is highly doubtful that a Celestial body
located so close to a star could
possibly have survived a supernova event
it is more realistic to assume that the
exop planet formed after the progenitor
Star had come to the end of its life
cycle and had transformed itself into a
pulsar the exoplanet could be a piece of
debris left over from a white dwarf
whose material would have dispersed for
the most
part this makes classifying the
exoplanet an especially difficult task
still whatever it is this world remains
one of the most dangerous and hostile
ones lurking in the depths of the cosmos
[Music]
650 light years away from the earth
there lies IRC +
10216 a Majestic Star also known as CW
leonis its radius at its pulsation Peak
May reach
560 times that of the sun which is about
2.6 times the distance from the Earth to
our parent star with CW leonis
hypothetically placed in the middle of
our system all the planets as far as
Mars would find themselves under its
surface which would even brush the inner
boundary of the asteroid belt
incidentally the star's mass is not that
great roughly 1.5 to four solar masses
its surface temperature is just 2,300 K
or about 2000° C
but due to its impressive Dimensions the
star emits on average 8 and a half
thousand times more energy than our
sun like any other red giant CW leonis
is in its final life stage its age
hasn't been defined precisely but it is
estimated to be several billion years it
is assumed that in its Salad Days CW
leonus was a white blue star with a mass
three to five times that of the Sun
however by 1 billion years ago a great
part of the celestial body's hydrogen
had burned out and transformed into
helium slowly settling in the stars
center the helium ousted all the
remaining hydrogen and formed a
scorching hot core which did not
participate in any thermonuclear
reactions this process typical for All
Stars whose mass is close to that of the
sun is the starting point for a Stars
transformation into a red giant the
star's inner pressure causes it to
expand to Great proportions which
renders the outer layers more rarified
and
unstable the space object's diameter
grows to be dozens of times greater with
its color gradually assuming a blood red
Hue a thermonuclear reaction still takes
place in the Stars depths which causes
the pressure and temperature of the
Stellar plasma to increase at a certain
point this unleashes a chain reaction of
nuclear fusion where helium nuclei are
transformed into carbon this is the cord
helium flash it is a complex multi-level
physical process that dramatically
transforms the Stars inner structure
with its score incredibly heating up its
outer layers on the contrary cool off
and
darken there are currently great amounts
of carbon in CW leonis but its Mass
isn't sufficient to hit the next level
of
nucleosynthesis as a result the
thermonuclear combustion in the object's
interior becomes unstable the Stellar
matter gradually cools off and shrinks
under the influence of gravitation this
heats up the star's interior again and
the reaction is Unleashed with a new
Force after receiving a new portion of
thermal energy the Stellar matter
expands again and the combustion dies
down it is assumed that this cyclic
process underlies the occasional changes
of the star's
Luminosity CW leonis has a
649 Day bation cycle and with a
Luminosity at its PE is
11,300 times brighter than the sun with
the Luminosity at its lowest meanwhile
the object emits
6,250 times more energy than the
Sun at the moment of contraction the
upper layers of Stellar matter partly
detach themselves from the
Star this forms a carbon oxygen gas
nebula that the star is enveloped
in According to some estimates CW leonus
loses 4 * 10 to the power of 22 tons of
material every year on account of this
process and amount approximately seven
times the mass of the
Earth observations show that the
circumstellar nebula is not less than
69,000 years old and its mass is about
1.5 times that of the
Sun as for its size it reaches 84,000
astronomical
units the nebula has an elaborate
structure with bulges and pockets of gas
as well as half arcs and irregular Rings
it is posited that these formations
appeared due to Magnetic activity and
Stellar Wind generated by the unstable
star close
by the chemical composition of the Cloud
CW leonis is shrouded in is of great
interest to explorers spectral analysis
data reveals it to contain around 70
different chemical compounds for example
carbon dioxide water and ammonia to name
but a
few there are also quite a lot of
elements from the upper part of melev's
periodic table right down to
iron CW leonis may have had planets in
the past but they appear to have been
swallowed up early on at the stage of
expansion
in any event years of observations did
not reveal distinct traces of their
existence in the past what was
registered was subtle changes in the
stars orbit back in
1994 and more recently in
2017 mysterious shifts of matter were
detected in the cloud of gas and dust
enveloping the
star some small red dwarf orbiting the
giant could well account for these
phenomena although attempts to detect
its radiation have so far been
unsuccessful this could be due to the
nebula close by which disperses and
reflects the energy flow from sources of
light located
nearby this phenomenon camouflages any
objects in the immediate environs and
prevents them from being accurately
recognized the mass of CW Leon's
hypothetical Stellar companion is
assumed to be definitely smaller than
that of the sun and it should take it
approximately 100 years to complete full
orbit around the giant another
outstanding feature is a comparatively
high water content in the stars environs
and envelope at first it was posited
that the star would melt and swallow up
icy comets as it
expanded however observations carried
out in 2009 showed the temperature of
some spectral lines to reach 1,000
Kelvin which is Possible only on
condition that water vapor forms
actually in the upper layers of the
Giant this fact did not fit in the model
of red giants structure accepted at the
time According to which all oxygen in
Stell matter necessary for water
synthesis must be used up completely to
produce carbon
monoxide a new hypothesis was put
forward to account for the witnessed
phenomena which stated that molecules of
silicon oxides and carbon are destroyed
by a powerful ultraviolet radiation
after that the released oxygen reacts
with hydrogen and there forms scor ing
hot water vapor the weakness of this
hypothesis is on the failure to account
for the source of ultraviolet
radiation reactions like that may occur
only in rather high temperatures that is
within Stella matter however it is
practically impervious to cosmic
rays this Paradox may be explained by
yet another assumption since the star is
unstable large ruptures and low density
areas occasionally occur on its surface
where ultraviolet radiation is not
blocked out that
effectively the water Vapor's overall
mass and the star's atmosphere and outer
layers is estimated at several
quintilian
tons enormous though this figure may
seem in fact water accounts for just
around a billionth of the star's overall
Mass according to today's Notions of
Stellar Evolution being a red giant CW
leonis is in its Autumn years now it
will deplete its Stell F in the next 10
to 30,000 years after which it will
discard its outer layers following a
powerful explosion it will transform
into an incredibly hot and dense space
object a white
dwarf its mass will be roughly 80% that
of the Sun and its temperature will
reach several million degre in the first
seconds after the
transformation however with no energy
source it is destined to slowly and
revocably fade in the course of billions
of years to
follow eventually the celestial body
will be almost invisible against the
background of cosmic emptiness when it
becomes a mysterious black
dwarf but this will not happen anytime
soon the shock wave and the mindboggling
temperature in the epicenter will
generate new elements that are not to be
found in a star's interior for example
uranium gold or lead they will later
become part of new celestial objects
millions of years later yet radioactive
decay will heat the planet's Interiors
melt the ice and saturate the oceans
with microelements thus creating
conditions for the Genesis of
life the universe is constantly evolving
and Global cataclysms and destruction
are an inalienable part of this process
but at the end of every storm there are
fresh rays of
[Music]
light temperatures of any stars
Interiors are incredibly High it is
hardly surprising as thermonuclear
synthesis that is the main energy source
of all stars can take place only in
these extreme conditions when two atoms
of hydrogen merge they produce an atom
of helium and release an electron and
several
neutrinos in addition a great amount of
energy is released during the process
still the hydrogen helium synthesis
isn't the only process that heats up
stars at higher temperatures other
elements may take part in chemical
reactions as well for example lithium
carbon or oxygen in this case cause of
heavier elements are produced such as
sulfur magnesium or
phosphorus their charge is higher and
they repel each other more
robustly much more energy is needed to
overcome this
resistance when a main sequence star
depletes most of its hydrogen Supply it
starts to expand and cool off with time
it ends up as a red giant it will
continue to burn due to thermonuclear
reactions of helium transforming into
carbon and oxygen the lighter the star
however the less time it will continue
to
burn eventually becoming unstable it
sheds its outer layers and goes
Supernova this leaves it a white dwarf
with no resources to fuel any
thermonuclear reactions
anymore with all its energy sources
depleted it is forced to gradually cool
off interestingly when the mass of a
star is higher than a certain value
heavy thermonuclear synthesis may become
the star's main energy source even after
all hydrogen has been used up such
celestial objects are referred to as
wolf rette
Stars this class of space objects was
discovered back in 1867 by the French
astronomers Charles wolf and George
rayette the scientist's attention was
scored by anomalously bright emission
lines of heavy elements in these Stars
Spectra as for the inner makeup of these
unusual celestial objects it was
accounted for much
later stars of this class are generally
heavy they have quite a meager supply of
hydrogen and are in the final stages of
their
Revolution wolfrad stars are extremely
rare to date just a few hundred of them
have been discovered in our
galaxy as for their overall count in the
Milky Way It Is estimated that there
can't be over 2,000 celestial objects of
this
class wolf rad stars are subdivided into
three main sequences depending on the
prevalent element in in the Spectrum
nitrogen carbon and oxygen
sequences each of them in its turn is
subdivided into several
types as for the hottest star in the
studied Universe it falls into the
category of the oxygen spectral sequence
ones the celestial body which is now
known as
w102 was discovered back in
1971 at first it was mistaken for the
optical counterpart of the X-ray source
gx3 3 +
1 however further observations revealed
that there were two completely different
objects according to data acquired
thanks to spectral analysis the
discovered Star had unusually bright
oxygen lines in its radiation
Spectrum thus in
w102 and four more bright stars became
the first to form a new
class spectral analysis showed that the
Stars surface temperature reaches over
210,000 Kelvin this makes
wr102 approximately 36 times as hot as
our
sun the Luminosity of the scorching hot
object is
unbelievable it is estimated at over
380,000 times that of the
sun w102 lies about 10,000 l years away
the star is located in the part of the
sky with the constellation
Sagittarius incidentally in spite of its
exceptionally High Luminosity it can't
be seen with a naked eye as it is too
far away from
us
w102 currently belongs to the extremely
rare Star Glass
W2 containing great amounts of oxygen
and almost no hydrogen it mainly relies
on the merging of heavy cores of such
elements as neon carbon and oxygen as
its sources of energy to date only nine
objects of this class have been
discovered with four of them located in
the Milky Way and the other five in
other
galaxies there are two factors that make
oxygen spectral sequence Stars rare
firstly there are very few of wolf rad
Stars around because only stars with a
mass not less than 40 solar masses are
potential candidates to become ones
secondly this class represents the final
stage of evolution of stars of this type
the stage May last anything from a th000
to 10,000 years which is mere seconds in
astronomical
terms being of comparatively modest
Dimensions wr102 is notably quite a
dense star with its radius measuring
just 58% that of the sun its mass on the
other hand is estimated at 15 to 18 so
masses on its birth it is thought to
have been as heavy as 40 to 60 cellular
masses still the high temperature and
robust chemical reactions in the Stars
interior cause an exceptionally powerful
Stellar Wind whose particles velocity is
over 5,000
km/s it takes wr102 just a few months to
lose one Earth Mass worth of material on
account of its Stellar
Wind at this rate of particle emission
the star is going to lose one Sun Mass
worth of material in the course of
10,000
[Music]
years there are no planets orbiting
w102 but it is shrouded in a gas
envelope not dense and exposed to
powerful ultraviolet radiation and
strong Stellar Wind the envelope gets
contracted and ionized which sustains
its elaborate structure of protuberances
and arches all around the star according
to a supposed Theory the gas cloud
around w102 May probably be remnants of
the former hydrogen outer layer of the
star another theory maintains that the
cloud came to be as a result of the
particle flow emitted by the
star wr102 is not the only outstandingly
blistering place in the universe for
example
w142 w30 A and W
93b as well as the central Stein the bug
nebula NGC
6302 are as hot as around 200,000 Kelvin
some white dwarfs may have almost the
same surface
temperature however all these are no
match to neutron stars when neutron
stars are born their temperatures May
reach a staggering 100 billion Kelvin
active neutrino emissions cool them off
comparatively rapidly but either way the
surface temperature of of any neutron
star is never less than a few hundred,
Kelvin as for their cause they must
admittedly be hotter
still having said that it is highly
improbable that the ultimate temperature
record is ever going to be beaten
according to today's cosmological
Concepts the temperature of the universe
at the moment of the hypothetical Big
Bang was approximately 1.4 * 10^ 32
Kelvin a fundamental Al physical
constant this value is referred to as
the plank temperature contemporary
physics is not capable of defining a
substance of a higher temperature as
physical laws are distorted Beyond any
recognition in such incredibly harsh
conditions quite beyond our
imagination getting back to
wr102 judging by the data we have on
Stellar Evolution today this star is in
its Autumn years now as opposed to Main
sequence Stars wolf rette stars do not
expand in their final stages of Life
their substantial Mass holds all the
stars material together in a dense and
hot
ball however after losing a lot of its
mass through Stellar Wind the object
will eventually get
destabilized if current estimates are
accurate
w102 appears to be ready to go super
over at any point in the next 1,500
years bearing in mind that the distance
between the star and the Earth is 10,000
light years it is highly likely that the
event has already taken place a
supernova would have been accompanied by
an extra powerful gamma ray flare
fortunately our planet is too far away
to suffer any pentious effects of this
dangerous emission
w102 is comprised of rather heavy
chemical elements and divon iron its
later Evolution will force it to
contract to a critical point the great
explosion bringing the star's life cycle
to a close will unleash processes of
robust proton and neutron capture this
way still heavier elements form
including transuranium ones eventually
wr102 will be replaced by a neutron star
a Celestial body unbelievably hot and
dense the former Stars outer layers
disrupted by the explosion will form a
nebula slowly cooling off it will give
off heat to the space around it many
billions of years later this material
will be able to form a new planetary
system until a short time ago it was uy
scooty that used to be considered the
largest star known to mankind for a long
while located 9 and a 12,000 light years
away from the sun the star is so
staggeringly enormous that it would
cover areas Beyond Jupiter's orbit where
it placed in the center of the solar
system its radius May reach
1,900 those of the Sun and its volume
may be over 5 billion times that of the
sun however recently and new giant has
claimed the title of the largest star in
the known universe it is known as
Stevenson
2-18 or rsgc
2-18 the star lies approximately 20 ,000
light years away from the Sun and is
part of the open cluster Stevenson 2
although According to some scientists
this space object should not be
associated with the Stevenson cluster as
it wouldn't be accurate either way
Stevenson 2-18 is located in the scutum
constellation and continues to Bear its
original
name the star itself was cataloged in
the all Sky database back in the
1990s but giant clouds of cosmic dust
largely interfered with observation of
the star clusters in the scutum
constellation obscuring them from any
Observer anxious to find out more only
in 2020 were scientists able to acquire
data about its size and the information
proved to be
astonishing According to some estimates
the radius of Stevenson 2-18 May reach
up to 1 and A2 billion kilm which is 10
times the distance from our Earth to the
Sun or 2,100 50 times the radius of the
Sun this means that the super Giant's
volume should be about 10 billion times
that of the sun placed in the center of
the solar system Stevenson 2-18 would
easily swallow up Saturn along with all
of its rings and moons to say nothing of
the terrestrial
planets interestingly it would take
light almost 8 and a half hours to
travel the length of this gigantic Stars
Equator this is the same time it takes
sunlight to reach Pluto at the remotest
point of its
orbit the super Giant's Luminosity is
estimated to reach
440,000 times du to the sun although its
surface temperature is comparatively low
at about
3,200 Kelvin this is about two times as
little as that of the Sun and
corresponds to the Red Band of the light
spectrum this is the reason why
Stevenson 2-18 falls into the category
of red super
Giants also this relatively low
temperature implies that most of the
Stars radiation is in the visible and
thermal Spectra with amounts of deathly
ultraviolet and Dex Ray types of
radiation rather negligible in
comparison it may seem strange that in
spite of its impressive dimensions and
sufficient Luminosity Stevenson 2-18
cannot be seen from the earth with a
naked eye but this has to do with its
low surface temperature as well as
clouds of stard dust and gas shrouding
the Giant star thus concealing it from
observers on our Earth they absorb and
disperse the star's light and this poses
difficulties for studying the object the
mass of Stevenson 2-8 Still Remains to
be gauged however supposing its inner
makeup is similar to that of uy scooty
and other super Giants it should be
anything within 20 solar masses if it is
the case the average density of super
giants like that must be extremely low
and almost equal to the density of the
Earth's atmosphere at a height of about
90 km above the sea level that is
practically on the border with
space it is really amazing that
thermonuclear energy that is the kind of
energy that gives a glow to a star is
still sustained in such conditions super
giant sizes are so mindboggling that
these objects are hardly steady most of
them are variable in terms of their
luminosity and as a the rule this
variability is
unpredictable no wonder as the
overwhelming majority of super Giants
are in the final stages of their life
cycles which means that they may go
supernova literally at any
moment according to the Contemporary
scientific concepts of Stellar Evolution
it is stars with original masses from 10
to 40 that of the Sun that qualify to
become red super Giants at a later stage
of their
existence thermonuclear reactor in their
interior rapidly burn out all hydrogen
thus turning it into helium after that
Fusion reactions of helium carbon oxygen
and lithium become the chief energy
source of the star life expectancy of
stars of this kind is comparatively
short just a few million years as it
evolves the prospective super giant
rapidly expands in size and loses its
mass on account of strong solar
wind clouds of Stardust and gas Gast
surrounding the original Star are
quickly absorbed by the new Star which
keeps swelling Way Beyond its original
size at an astonishing rate however its
own solar wind creates a new nebula
around the star on account of the short
lifespan of this kind of star no planets
can realistically originate in this
nebula eventually the super giant
explodes following the Supernova or even
hypernova event the outer layers of the
star are hurled away and then gradually
cool off forming a nebula as for the
former core it becomes either a neutron
star or a black hole depending on its
mass by the way feel free to see our
previous videos about dwarf stars and
supern
noi a hypernova event is accompanied by
a high energy x-ray burst powerful
enough to eliminate any life within the
radius of several light years luckily
for us and the Earth all super Giants
identified by scientists so far Li
considerably further than that so we
seem to be safe from those due to active
radiation of charged particles the
rotation of stars of this type gradually
slows down and eventually their outer
layers practically grind to a halt the
core of the star meanwhile continues to
rotate quite unabated and there may be a
substantial difference between the speed
of the core and that of the outer layer
taking into consideration the high
Luminosity low temperature and
impressive dimensions on balance it is
safe to assume that the habitable zone
of Stevenson 2-8 should be really huge
its middle should lie approximately
663 astronomical units away from the
stars center in other words 20 times the
distance from the center of the sun to
Pluto's orbit and as for the area of the
habitable zone it is expected to be one
billion times that of the sun scientists
do admit of the possibility of the
existence of planetary systems around
super Giants but what with these Stars
short lifespan and unstable conditions
the chances are almost negligible at any
rate no confirmed exoplanets have so far
been discovered in the environs of one
Stevenson 2-8 lies so far away that its
light travels to our Earth for 20,000
years for all we know at this very
moment its core might be shrinking to
form an extremely dense neutron star
with red H shards of outer layers flying
away in all directions to become part of
ice cold
space but mankind will be able to find
this out only in a very distant
future long before telescopes had been
invented people could observe a light
strip crossing the heavens the
fascinating and mysterious phenomenon
prompted a multitude of Legends but it
took thousands of years of scientific
progress to finally account for
it it turned out that the Milky Way
wasn't a path of gods what it is is the
dissipated light of billions of stars
too remote to distinguish each one
separately the idea of the Stars around
us making up part of a single structure
of enormous Dimensions was first
suggested by Emanuel C back in
1755 he also assumed that some nebula
discovered by scientist
could in fact be remote star clusters
that is other
galaxies this ingenious guess was well
ahead of its time with the philosophers
contemporaries initially dismissing it
only in the early 20th century did the
progress of observation equipment Ena
scientists to confirm the existence of
other galaxies and in
1936 Edwin Hubble devised a
classification system many of its
principles are still referred to by
scientists today
day according to the system the Milky
Way falls into the category of barred
spiral galaxies although it took a long
while before it had assumed its today's
looks our galaxy is quite a old one
since the stars in its Central globular
clusters were born as far back as around
13 billion years
ago at the same time there are some
areas in the Milky Way where stars are
actively born which means that there is
always a fresh supply of young Stars
the collected data points to the fact
that the Milky Way is a comparatively
large Galaxy in astronomical terms the
diameter of its disc measures as much as
200,000 light years with a Halo reaching
out into space much deeper yet our
galaxy is home to at least 200 billion
various stars as well as 25 to 100
billion Brown dwarves in addition it
contains over a trillion planets
countless small celestial objects as
well as clouds of cosmic dust and
Interstellar gas which may reach
gigantic
Dimensions at the same time regular
matter accounts for a small ratio in the
Galaxy around 90% of the Milky Way's
overall mass is the so-called Dark
Matter the amount of light emitted by
this mysterious and widespread substance
is
negligible however Dark Matter plays an
active role in gravitational
interaction even though most of the
galactic Mass remains invisible we can
still calculate it to that end
scientists refer to stars trajectories
of movement around the center of the
Milky
Way according to the estimates the
overall mass of our galaxy reaches 8 to
1.5 trillion solar
masses the structure of the Milky Way is
quite
elaborate we'll start our journey today
from its
Center this area of the the Galaxy is
shrouded in massive clouds of gas and
dust but by happy chance we can observe
it through the so-called bis window an
area of space with lower amounts of
dust just like most spiral galaxies the
Milky Way has a super massive black hole
in its Center which is surrounded with
an accretion disc with a radius roughly
three light
years dubbed Sagittarius A star it is
the closest object of this class to us
its mass is 4.3 million solar masses and
its radius isn't over 16 million km
which is three times smaller than
Mercury's
orbit the First Data about the nature of
the object in the center of our galaxy
was acquired in the course of long
observations and thorough calculations
only as recently as on May 12th 2022 was
it possible to get the first image with
the help of the EHD network of radio
telescopes and and so the earlier
hypotheses were confirmed the area in
the center of our galaxy is highly
populated more than 6,000 stars have
already been detected within three light
years from the black hole with the
orbits of some of them defined rather
accurately for example there is a white
blue star designation
s62 which is 17.8 astronomical units
away from the black hole on its closest
approach to it while moving at 6.7% the
speed of light classical mechanics laws
are inadequate for description of the
trajectory of movement of a star as
Swift as that because of relativistic
effects just to illustrate the axis of
its orbit shifts by 75 angular minutes
with every completed orbit besides when
Crossing this area in space we can see
several large star clusters with a total
mass of around 1 million solar masses
and slightly further roughly 200 Li
years of away another massive black hole
is likely to be lurking whose Mass
should be around 100,000 times that of
the
sun traveling further on we will reach
the central molecular cloud and a
regularly shaped area measuring 1600 to
19900 Li years whose mass is over 60
million solar masses there are a great
many Stellar nurseries and gas nebula as
well as protostars and remnants of
supernova most of the cloud matter is
dense hydrogen whose temperature
fluctuates between 50 and 600 kin which
corresponds to
223° C below 0 to
327° C above 0 spectral analysis shows
the gigantic nebula to contain carbon
monoxide methyl alcohol and hydrocyanic
acid in addition to
hydrogen having receded from the Milky
Way Center a bit we will see that it is
encompassed by a bulge a bright and
massive formation of an elliptical shape
with its length reaching 10,000 light
years its transverse diameter is roughly
7 light years the total mass of the
Bulge is as much is 10 billion times
that of the Sun the exact number of the
Stars cannot be calculated because their
radiation Blends and renders any
estimates
unrealistic being elongated the Bulge
for forms the so-called bar stretching
for approximately 13,000 light years and
serving as the base for spiral Galactic
arms it is here at one of its hands that
we can see the star cluster Stevenson 2
containing the largest known star today
its designation is Stevenson
2-18 and its radius is
2,150 times that of the
sun unfortunately chances of finding
exoplanets or orbiting this outstanding
object are quite minuscule even if
planets did exist at some point in the
past the hyper giant would have
swallowed them M while it was expanding
the Galaxy's Center is home to billions
of stars and apparently a great number
of
exoplanets chances of encountering a
potentially habitable World among this
great multitude are much lower than in
less populated areas of the Galaxy this
is due to the fact that when a big
number of stars are located close
together they destabilize exoplanets
orbits while their powerful radiation is
lethal to all living
things that is why a special area in the
galaxy is defined as the habitable zone
it looks like a ring with a radius
measuring 22 to 29,000 light years and
contains star systems with the most
favorable conditions for the Genesis of
biological
life worlds encompassed by the ring
languish in exposure to ESS of radiation
while beyond the ring there's a lack of
heavy
elements however mathematical modeling
shows that stars within galaxies are
able to migrate thousands of light years
away thus either leaving the habitable
zone or entering it consequently with an
exoplanet lying within the Zone it does
not automatically suggest favorable
conditions on
it moving on away from the center of the
Milky Way we will have a chance to check
out its most impressive part the
galactic
disc it is made up of two components
with different properties the first one
known as the Thin disc measures 1,000 to
1,300 Li years and thickness and its
visible radius measures as much as
50,000 Li years on the edge it gradually
dissipates with the outermost Stars
lying up to 100,000 light years away
from the Galaxy's Center
this part of the Milky Way contains
around 80% of the Galaxy's visible mass
and in fact it was the last component to
have formed as for the thick disc its
diameter is comparable to that of the
thin disc but it's four times as thick
and is much more
rarified it is made up of old stars and
is practically devoid of interstellar
gas observations of some stars in the
Milky Way as well as mathematical
modeling show our galaxy to have
swallowed up a another one in the period
from 11 to 8 billion years ago this
hypothetical Cosmic structure was dubbed
Gia
Enceladus it is thought that it
contributed several billion stars to the
Milky Way as well as great amounts of
interstellar gas and dark matter it is
thanks to this tremendous event that
most of our galaxy thick disc formed and
an additional supply of gas led to a
stellar Baby
Boom there is no doubt that spiral arms
are the most noticeable structural
elements of our Galaxy's disc usually
two major ones are singled out The
scutum Centaurus arm and the pereus arm
and two minor ones the Norma arm and the
Kina Sagittarius arm sometimes a fifth
large arm is taken into account named
after the signis
constellation Galactic arms are areas of
especially High star count most of
interstellar gas is also concentrated
here which is why the rate of star for
formation in the arms is 3 to 5 times
higher than in the Galaxy on
average they spend the first millions of
their lives in open clusters but gravity
forces are too weak to hold the Stars
close together for a long time this
destabilizes the Clusters and young
Stars gradually drift away from each
other traveling along the Kina
Sagittarius arm we will reach a fork
that links it to the perus arm the
length of this Stellar structure reaches
11,000 light years and its width
measures roughly
3,500 light years it is referred to ASD
Orion arm and it is here 27,000 light
years away from the Galaxy's Center that
the solar system is
located from our planet's perspective
the Galaxy's Center is seen as a dark
abyss this is the Great Rift an area of
space that shuts out the greater part of
the milky away from our gaze it is
filled with massive clouds of
interstellar gas and dust and its total
mass is as much as a million times that
to the sun even though the great drift
is practically not transparent in the
optical range its matter actively emits
radio waves and thermal energy spectral
analysis data reveals that the clouds
are mostly made up of hydrogen with a
small percentage of more complex
compounds ammonia alcohols and amino
acids the Great Rift is thought to be a
potential Stellar Nursery but it is
going to take a while until the first
Stars light up in that
area while it is still not quite active
let's move on beyond the Galaxy disc
even though its bright and clearly
defined arms attract a lot of attention
there is more to the Milky Way than
that if we look closer we will see the
vastest and the most rarified of its
components
the
Halo its visible part spherical in shape
stretches for up to 260,000 light years
away from the Galaxy's Center but
accounts for just a few per of the total
mass the Halo contains a great number of
globular clusters made up of remarkably
old Stars over 12 billion years of age
and several tremendous Stellar
streams the Sagittarius stream for
example made up of several thousand
stars in encompasses our galaxy in an
elongated Ellipsis which is almost
perpendicular to the main plane modeling
shows that all these stars are highly
likely to have been gravitationally
captured by the Milky Way from a dwarf
satellite Galaxy designation Sagittarius
D it lies 500,000 light years away from
the Milky Way Center and is going to be
swallowed up by it completely within
several billion
years another dwarf galaxy has already
met a similar fate
lying in the Canis Major constellation
it was almost destroyed by the Milky Way
which pulled out millions of its Stars
by gravity
forces stretching for 200,000 light
years and mixing with other stars this
string of stars with a total mass of
roughly 100 million solar masses has
already wrapped around our galaxy three
times apart from Bright but rare stars
and clusters the Halo contains great
amounts of gas whose temperature reaches
millions of Kelvin also great amounts of
dark matter are thought to be scattered
in the vicinity of the Milky Way forming
the so-call dark
Halo stretching for up to 2 million
light years it hardly emits any
electromagnetic radiation and can be
detected only by gravitational
interaction the dark Halo remains an
unsolved mystery yet it greatly
contributes to the global stability of
our galaxy
distances from the Milky Way to other
galaxies are by all accounts
mindboggling as a rule it is an from
Millions to billions of light years due
to the universe's cosmological expansion
the distance between the Earth and any
remote object in the universe is
constantly growing which makes the light
emanating from this object look rder
than it actually is this phenomenon is
known as a red shift it is of great
health help engaging distances and
velocities on the astronomical
scale alternatively some galaxies
spectrum is blue shifted which means
that they're not on an escape trajectory
from us but on the contrary are moving
to meet us one of these unusual space
objects is the galaxy m86 in the Virgo
cluster roughly 52 million light years
away from the Sun it is moving towards
the Milky Way at a speed of around
244 km/s which makes it one of the
fastest moving blue shifted
galaxies by moving at a high speed
through the scattered gas the Virgo
cluster is filled with m86 is constantly
shedding its own Interstellar
matter as a result of this process it
leaves a trail of long lines of warm
ionized hydrogen behind m86 is connected
with the almost destroyed spiral galaxy
NGC
4438 with several of these
filaments these two galaxies are thought
to have collided at some point in the
distant past which was the smaller ones
undoing interestingly m86 is known to
have destroyed its other neighbors in
the past as well several Stellar streams
have been detected in its Halo that are
likely to be the remains of smaller
galaxies absorbed earlier an impressive
number of globular clusters in its
structure is another outstanding feature
of
m86 observations show that their number
is upwards of 3,000 800 which is around
25 times as many as in the Milky Way
There is a theory that claims these
clusters to be the remains of dwarf
galaxies that m86 would have absorbed in
the past if it really is the case then
it would have destroyed 10 or even
hundreds of other galaxies having said
that m86 looks anything but unique the
Galaxy es 137 D1 which we'll be looking
at next has a similar shape but unlike
m86 it appears more outlandishly
original located
227 million Li years away from the Sun
it is as heavy as 5 to 14 billion solar
masses as for its Stars most of them are
young and bright blue giants ESO
137-001 in its turn is part of Abel
3627 a large Galaxy
cluster moving to its Center at an
incredible speed of almost 2,000 km/s
the Galaxy collides with Interstellar
gas pressure inside the cluster as a
result its own gas is blown out leaving
behind tails that stretch for up to
260,000 light years incidentally the
mass of interstellar gas in those areas
is 2 to four times that of the gas
inside the Galaxy it is hardly
surprising that star bursts are a common
thing here that is Stars don't stop
forming in these enormous streams made
up mostly of hydrogen when seen from the
side ESO
1371 appears like a Giant jellyish
floating through endless expanses of
space unfortunately as the Galaxy is
continuously stripped of its
Interstellar gas its life expectancy
diminishes too with not much material
left no new stars can form here which
greatly affects the structure of the
Spiral arms and Central bulge of the
Galaxy on the bright side s have a
chance of finding out more about dark
matter and its interaction with other
space objects by observing the behavior
of the gas streams left in the Galaxy
wake speaking about the formation of
newer stars there is a galaxy with a
name that speaks for itself Baby Boom
around 4,000 Stars Are Born here every
year which is about 400 times more than
in the Milky Way straightforward
calculations show that on average and US
star lights up in this area of space
every 2
hours the baby boom Galaxy lies around
12.2 billion light years away from the
earth this means that what we see when
observing it is what was happening just
1 and a half billion years after the
hypothetical Big
Bang it was a time when the universe was
still in the process of forming its
structure what is taking place in the
Galaxy now is drastically different from
what we expect to observe there in
theory based on what we know about star
formation the reasons why stars are
produced here at such an astounding rate
are not known yet but it is beyond any
doubt that baby boom is able to provide
us with a lot of information about the
early stages of our universe's
Evolution one of the few galaxies one
can observe through an Amer telescope is
the so-called Sombrero Galaxy official
designation
m104 it lies 30 million light years away
from the Sun and it's diameter is
roughly four times smaller than that of
the Milky Way the sombrero Galaxy's
outstanding feature is a massive ring of
dust and cold hydrogen enveloping it
observations show that it is here that
most young Stars Are
Born In addition to The Peculiar ring
the Sombrero Galaxy is also remarkable
for its elaborate inner
makeup observations with a spitzer Space
Telescope show that most stars in this
galaxy form a structure typical of
elliptical galaxies the Stars here are
mostly rather old yellow and red dwarves
the other stars here on the other hand
form spiral structures concealed within
an elliptical Cloud it is thought that
this phenomenon is a result of two
galaxies collision with their Stars
subsequently and almost inevitably
mingling together it is incredible that
the galactic structures survived a merge
of that scale with minimal damage are
none the worse for this tremendous
collision and can still be observed
another peculiar feature in the Sombrero
Galaxy is exceptionally powerful x-ray
radiation emanating from the center it
is assumed that the accre disc of a
super massive black hole may be its
source the mass of the hole is estimated
to be over a billion solar masses which
makes this enormous object one of the
most massive black holes known to
science
today there are also several sources of
tremendously high frequency or terahertz
radiation detected within the Galaxy
although today their nature is still a
mystery our Galactic parade today is
concluded with yet another object
boasting an elaborate inner structure
the Eerie m64 Galaxy rather aply dubbed
the black eye Galaxy the nickname comes
from a dark band of cosmic dust that
partly conceals the Galaxy's center from
The Observer on the earth due to this
line of cosmic dust as well as the
exceptionally bright active nucleus it
is impossible to estimate made the black
ey's number of stars even roughly what
we do know is that it is comparatively
small and not so remote its radius
measures 25,000 light years and it lies
approximately 17 million light years
away from the Milky Way the black eye
Galaxy is made up of two well- defined
Parts interestingly the inner disc with
a bulge rotate in the direction opposite
to that of the outer
ring the most likely explanation for
such a bizarre makeup is that the Galaxy
formed after two smaller ones collided
and merged in the distant past
admittedly it would take a combination
of a number of mutually independent
factors for such a fascinating and
well-defined structure to form for
example the progenitor galaxies would
have moved at specific velocities and
come together at a certain angle the
odds of a success would have been
minuscule the the solar system is just
one of the countless multitude of
planetary systems scattered across our
galaxy as we know it consists of a
single star in its main sequence stage
and date planets with their satellites
in addition our system contains over a
million small celestial bodies like
asteroids comets and meteoroids the
planet in the solar system lying
furthest at least that we know of is
Neptune its Orbit's radius measures
around 30 astronomical units which is
equivalent to approximately four light
hours amazingly only a tiny portion of
the solar system is encompassed by
Neptune's orbit the remotest object in
the system discovered to date is the
so-called far far out lying 132
astronomical units or 18 light hours
away from the Sun still even this object
barely visible against a dark background
of unfathomable space is not all close
to the hypothetical or Cloud whose inner
boundaries lie approximately 2,000
astronomical units away from the center
of our system according to some
estimates its outer boundaries stretch
for up to 60,000 astronomical units at
the very least which is around one light
here these limits are predefined by the
sun's gravitational influence and what
lies Beyond is Interstellar
space moving further away we will noce
over 50 of all kinds of stars within 20
light years from the Sun these stars are
really diverse from dim and cold Brown
dwarves to Bright and widely known
objects like Sirius proon and D some of
them have their own planetary systems
with objects potentially capable of
Nursing and sustaining life for example
the object known as gisa
832c which is 16.1 light years away from
the Sun is similar to our Earth more
than any other planet within the solar
system that we know
of the average temperature on the
exoplanet surface reaches 253 kin or 20°
C below 0 and it takes the astronomical
body just 36 Earth days to complete a
full orbit around its parent star in
astronomical standards the distance
between us and gleer 832c is relatively
small however as space probe setting out
from our system at a speed of roughly 17
km/s would take as much as 300,000 years
to reach the exoplanets environs at our
current level of technological
advancement it is impossible to design
an Interstellar spaceship capable of
completing as long a journey as
that the solar system together with its
neighbor stars is part of the Orion arm
the latter in its turn is part of the
Milky Way it contains around 400 billion
stars and potentially over a trillion
exoplanets of All Sorts can be
discovered there according to estimates
today the main diameter of the Milky Way
measures around 100,000 light years and
the Stellar Halo may be twice as large
even though the thickness of the main
disc measures about 1,000 light years
there is a clearly defined bulge in the
Galaxy's
Center this bulge is roughly 3,000 light
years thick the Milky Way is part of the
so-call local
group this is a vast structure
comprising over 50 galaxies concentrated
within an area of space measuring around
10 million light years in diameter the
Andromeda galaxy the triangulum Galaxy
and the Milky Way are the largest of the
lot some estimates show that the mass
total of the cluster May reach as much
as 3 trillion solar masses with our
galaxy and Andromeda accounting for the
major part with a distance from the
Earth to Andromeda around 2.5 million
light years it is considered to be our
closest galaxy not counting smaller or
dwarf
ones moving on to the next order the
local group forms part of the giant
Virgo supercluster made up of over
30,000 galaxies the supercluster is
located within an area of space with a
diameter of around 150 m ion light years
its mass total is as much as a
quadrillion solar masses or in other
words around a th000 galaxies like the
Milky Way the supercluster is quite
flattened and around 60% of all the
objects it is made up of appear like a
flat sheet around 10 million light years
thick staggering though it may appear on
the face of it this value is actually
small in terms of the large scale
structure of the
universe as we Zoom zoom out still more
we have a chance of seeing a giant
supercluster of galaxies approximately
520 million light years in
size called lakia it includes several
Galaxy
superclusters among others the Virgo
supercluster and the great attractor the
overall mass of this formation measures
approximately as much as 100 quadrillion
solar masses the greater tractor lies
roughly 250 million light years away
from our planet and is the gravitational
Center for all objects lying close by
astronomical standards it cannot be
observed from the earth directly as The
Milky Ways play thwarts it that is why
the nature of the great tractor Still
Remains an unsolved mystery
today lanaka is part of the large scale
structure of the universe an elaborate
system of Galactic filaments walls and
voids gargantuan areas of emptiness in
space some of these objects are really
incredibly
enormous for example the Hercules Corona
Borealis Great Wall stretches for around
a staggering 10 billion light years ever
since its Discovery in 2013 this
superstructure has been considered the
most gigantic component of the large
scale structure of the universe to all
appearances it must be home to millions
of galaxies and the number of stars it
contains will probably always Define
calculation the mere existence of a
structure like that is a mystery to
science as according to today's accepted
theory of universe's Evolution
gargantuan clusters like that are simply
not supposed to form but incidentally
this wall so enormous that the human
brain cannot fully appreciate its
Dimensions is still just a tiny portion
of the observable
universe according to today's
cosmological Notions space in the
universe is is continually expanding
with a speed of expansion depending on
the distance between objects the further
and observed object lies away from The
Observer the faster the distance between
the two
increases the rate at which the two
mutually recede is not limited by the
speed of light because it's actually
space matter that is expanding which
means that at a certain point the two
objects will be mutually unobservable
Relic radiation observation shows that
the area of the observable universe is a
sphere with a diameter roughly 93
billion light
years according to the theory of
relativity we can see and interact with
only those objects that are within this
sphere this conventional spherical area
in space is called The Meta Galaxy and
it may be either all of the universe or
again its tiny
portion for all we know hypothetically
there may well lie some unknown
structures beyond the visible boundaries
of space such entities are referred to
as extr metagalactic objects and
unfortunately it is impossible to study
them today with scientific methods still
some astronomical bodies on the edge of
the visible Universe appear to be moving
in ways different from what we would
naturally expect judging by the data we
have instances of anomalous movements
like those may be evidence of the
presence of some massive structures
beyond the matter Galaxy boundaries
their attraction pervades the space
around and influences objects around too
there is a whole plethora of hypotheses
as to the structure of the universe
beyond the meta Galaxy but most of them
are rather of metaphysical nature for
example some people believe that time
and space as we more or less know them
are non-existent beyond the boundaries
of the universe the physical laws we're
used to do not apply there either and
Notions of matter material or energy are
virtually senseless this hypothesis is
further elaborated on by the following
idea The Meta Galaxy accounts for just a
part of a yet more complex and larger
scale super structure in space whose
makeup and dimensions are too incredible
for us to imagine it is quite possible
that this structure could be in a
multi-dimensional space or else be based
on physical principles we have no idea
of this makes the meta Galaxy just an
insignificant addition to or a partial
reflection of this mindboggling super
structure According to some
interpretations of the anthropic
principle there are other worlds out
there beyond the boundaries of the
observable universe in those Worlds the
values of the fundamental constants like
the speed of light or the electron
charge are completely different this
hypothesis is in many ways supported by
the idea of a Multiverse which
schematically appears as foam with lots
of bubbles separated from each other by
thin walls but these walls are
impenetrable this makes every Universe a
separate space with its own physical
laws and for all we know these laws may
be totally different from the ones we're
used to the most radical hypotheses go
as far as to deny our world any
objective reality
whatsoever according to these the
universe is just a simulation like
virtual reality in computers but on an
incredibly advanced
level as a rule ideas like that imply
that there are some super beings or
super civilizations out there beyond the
reality we're used to whose level of
advancement is infinitely higher than
ours and whose goals and capabilities
are Arcane and
incomprehensible however it goes without
saying that it is hardly possible to
either confirm or repudiate these
[Music]
hypotheses of course distances in space
defy our imagination and are even
frightening they appear infinite from
the point of view of any person
today what we do know is that the
universe is expanding and provided this
process continues there will come a
point when space objects will disappear
one after another Beyond The Event
Horizon first galaxies then stars and
the world will immerse in Eternal
Darkness but by then there will be no
one around to witness
that
the famous American writer Ursula lwin
expresses her own thoughts through a
character in her book in these lines the
word must be heard in silence there must
be Darkness to see the
stars the phrase has to do with the
birth and death of all that
exists every object in the universe has
its beginning and its
send some subatomic particles last as
little as tenths of a
second some microorganisms live between
2 hours and several days man's life
expectancy counts several decades but
even Stars eventually burn out after
millions and billions of years of
existence and what about the universe
itself is it also going to come to an
end at some point what will it be like
and what will happen after its
death the earliest theory of the Genesis
of our world is what is known as theory
of the stationary universe or steady
state universe supporters of this Theory
claim that the Universe has no beginning
and no end it has always been and always
will be in its steady state of
equilibrium however very soon scientific
estimations proved this Theory likely to
be wrong as there are some irreversible
processes taking place in the universe
in the 1910s and 1920s The Big Bang
Theory was formulated and widely
popularized today it is one of the most
consistent scientific theories and it is
able to account for the universe's
Genesis and
evolution dozens of scientists
contributed to the development of The
Big Bang Theory and Albert Einstein's
works on the general theory of
relativity laid the Theory's Foundation
the main conclusion this Theory abled
scientists to arrive at is the
supposition that the fate of the
universe depends on Dark Energy a
theoretical type of energy causing space
to expand be it as it may at this point
it is quite impossible to say anything
definite about this physical phenomenon
there are a great number of theories
about this and each of them has its
praiseworthy aspects and shortcomings
according to data we possess today the
age of the universe is calculated from
the moment of the big bang and is
estimated it's slightly less than 14
billion years the universe is constantly
expanding and depending on the density
of dark energy it will either expand
Forever at a regularly increasing rate
or else the expansion will slow down and
reverse in this case the universe is
bound to compress into an infinitely
small Singularity similar to what it
originated from today science is not
ready to give a definite answer to the
question which of these two
possibilities will prevail however it is
ready to suggest at least two equally
possible scenarios of what may happen
next referred to as the big rip and the
Big
Crunch the universe's expansion rate is
proportional to distances between
objects the further some objects are
located from each other the higher the
expansion rate imagine a balloon pumped
with air there are two dots on it if we
pump still more air into the balloon the
dots will get further away from each
other that's the way the expansion of
the universe works it is space itself
that expands the further the dots are
initially located the faster they get
still further
apart at a certain point this rate
exceeds the speed of light this point is
known as The Event
Horizon all objects Beyond it disappear
from View and they Drift Away beyond the
reach of the most advanced telescopes
never to be observed
again just imagine first the remotest
galaxies and clusters will disappear
from the sky then one by one the Milky
Way Stars will fade away and to Crown it
all it will be the turn for our sun to
go dim what a gloomy
sight if the Big Rip Theory holds Good
the universe's expansion rate will be
constantly on the
increase this will lead to expansion
forces gradually overcoming gravity
forces following that first first Galaxy
clusters and then galaxies themselves
and star clusters will be broken up
after that it will be the turn for
Stellar systems to disintegrate as host
Stars will not have sufficient pool to
keep their planets and satellites from
floating away at the next stage matter
will be reduced to atoms and these will
be reduced to subatomic particles matter
will effectively cease to exist after
this physical laws as we know them will
cease to be and then any further
developments are quite impossible to
predict observations today show that
space expands and the expansion rate is
on the increase however we're not
familiar with the nature of dark energy
it may well have properties unknown to
us at this point and these May reverse
the expansion processes as a result the
universe will start Contracting this may
well happen if General gravitation
created by all matter in the universe
exceeds its expansion Force this
scenario is what is known as the Big
Crunch in this case processes in the
universe will run in the same manner
until its size decreases five times
Galaxy clusters will come together as
one super cluster which in essence will
fill the entire universe considerably
shrunk by this point meanwhile inside
the galaxies events like births and
deaths of stars Planet formation and so
on will keep taking place just like
before when the universe contracts 20
times more its volume will account for
just 1% of that of today's and all
galaxies will blend into one The Relic
radiation temperature by that time will
measure 274 de Kelvin and it will still
continue to grow this means that there
won't be any liquid water left in the
universe and water is vital for
biological Life as we know
it further contraction of space will
cause the universe to heat up even more
planets will first be burnt and and then
melted all matter will crumple into an
enormous cloud of boiling plasma after
that atoms and subatomic particles will
disperse and eventually the universe
will collapse into a singularity similar
to the one it used to be when it was
born there is a theory which is a kind
of a spin-off of the Big Crunch Theory
it is known as the big bounds Theory
according to the big bounds theory on
reaching the state of Singularity
following the Big Crunch
the universe will be reborn as a result
of yet another big bang and the cycle
will repeat itself again and again
supposedly forever as far as it is
possible to speak about eternity in
conditions devoid of time and space I
will repeat myself yet again by saying
that our knowledge about dark energy is
too meager to speak about the duration
of any of these scenarios for all we
know the next big rip or big crunch for
that matter will take place in a period
when there is still stars and planets
around but what if it isn't the case
what will happen to the universe if its
ultimate fate is still extremely remote
in
time still the laws of physics imply
that the universe as we more or less
know it can it exist forever there are
four clearly defined epochs in cosmology
and each of them is associated with this
or that particular phenomenon we live in
the so-called stelliferous era there is
a lot of interstellar gas in the parts
of the universe around us it is used as
raw material for stars to form from new
stars are born from this gas and the
process will continue until all
Interstellar gas has been
depleted this Sea Park is expected to be
over in the period from 1 to 100
trillion years from
now by that time the sun and the
overwhelming majority of other stars
will have depleted their nuclear fuel
subsequently turning into white dwarves
neutron stars or black
holes I've actually already spoken about
it in an earlier video the next era is
known as the degenerate
era there will not be any main sequence
Stars around anymore most matter in the
universe will remain in the form of
white and brown dwarves and some matter
will persist as neutron stars and black
holes it will take a great amount of
time for all these objects to cool off
around a duo dilion or 10 to the power
of 39
years white dwarves will gradually give
off their heat in the form of radiation
and become black dwarves as for brown
dwarves they will cool off too
thermonuclear reactions taking place in
their interior at a sluggish rate will
eventually stop completely gradually
most matter will be slurped by black
holes at this stage of the universe's
Evolution Dark Matter Annihilation and
protons disintegration will be the major
processes the proton is a saaton atomic
particle that atoms known to science are
built of it is considered one of the
most durable subatomic particles its
life expectancy as it were accounts for
approximately 100 dood deilan or 10 to
the power of 41 years now by the time
this era comes to an end matter in the
universe will look like a great ocean of
freely floating Elementary particles
with an occasional neutron star or black
hole tucked away among them the next era
is the black hole
era According to some theories black
holes will form clusters and eventually
blend together thus forming one single
gargantuan black hole alternative
theories suggest that black holes will
slowly evaporate while emitting energy
before Vanishing
completely black hole evaporation is a
Quantum effect produced by what is known
as Hawking radiation the smaller a hole
the more intensive its evaporation which
eventually strips the hole of all its
matter and energy this process is
supposed to persist for 10 to the power
of 100 years this number is also
referred to as
googal be it as it may eventually only
dead expanses of space will be left in
the universe this space will contain
debris leftover from processes having
taken place in the previous SE Parks
photons electrons positrons neutrinos
and quarks electrons and positrons will
collide thus causing Annihilation the
universe may exist in this state
practically Forever Until the next big
crunch or big rip at the very
least either way the humanity will be
long gone at that time its existance is
likely to be terminated in the
stelliferous era our planet meanwhile
will remain habitable for another
billion years or so and after that it
will be burnt by the ever intensifying
glow of the sun about 5 or 6 billion
years later our son by then a red giant
will shed its outer layers and become a
white dwarf but what will happen after
the universe dies disappointing as it is
there is absolutely no way we can answer
this question the trouble is whatever
the scenario there won't be either time
or space as we know them even if the big
bounce Theory or the Big Crunch theory
is right or else a new Big Bang takes
place thus giving birth to a new
universe with a fresh set of galaxies
and stars we will simply never find out
just like we will never find out what it
used to be like in the universe before
ours because the word must be heard in
silence there must be Darkness to see
the
stars dear friends this amazing journey
through the universe has come to an end
but there are many more discoveries to
come billions of stars and trillions of
planets still hold their secrets and it
will take a lot of time and effort to
unlock them that means that there are a
lot more and new educational episodes
about the mysteries of the universe up
ahead and let's keep in
[Music]
touch